donc mathieu on ne pouvait pas suivre
cette grande finale du speech s sans toi
entraîneur et coach bien connu dans le
milieu
c'est pas faux j'imagine que j'aurais
préféré commenter la petite sarah date
sera sa dette qu'elle me charest c'est
le redis ramat charrière et non mais
n'en apprennent honnêtement les deux
joueuses minutes complètement on est
juste un peu surfaite pas voir où ils
fans oui mais c'est un super affiche que
les deux ont vraiment super bien j'ai
regardé un peu le ton - ce matin les
deux amériques la demande est là c'est
super affiche toi tu disais tout à
l'heure que pour toi tu as fait la
favorite c'était kosteniuk moi je mets
ma douche et nina mais en vérité c'est
quasiment du 50-50 ne se sont pas joués
non et non je crois je crois va semble
pas sur le point de ne pas non plus une
enceinte après du coup c'est assez drôle
c'est que c'est pendant ce mois de
compétition ou trois semaines
j'ai regardé les partis des deux
joueuses parce que des deux fois dans le
jeu contre mon élève et je les défunts
pour la préparer pour pour l'événement
et du coup je vais être au fait des
ouvertures qu'elle joue normalement
c'est cool ça peut l'être après après il
ya un truc je l'avais j'y ai pensé à te
dire j'ai remarqué kosteniuk à un gros
point fort par rapport à beaucoup de
joueuses
quand il ya une ouverture qui se passe
mal elle peut changer tout seul oui
inchangé le chant elle change vite même
d'ailleurs je la change très vite des
cas voit qu'il ya anguille sous roche ou
non mais après ça m'étonne à moitié dans
le sens où tu sais est là elle a
beaucoup joué contre le top niveau mixte
elle a fait les championnats du monde de
blitz à moscou etc
je l'avais moi je l'avais vu jouer un
championnat du monde au blitz à moscou
elle se jouer à les crânes [ __ ]
compagnie pendant pendant pendant vingt
ronde quoi et on nous met par ailleurs
elle avait peut-être les crânes mi 2014
oui et je pense que
je pense que ça fait énormément
progresser de jouer contre des joueurs
de ce niveau là mathieu eu évidemment
heureux non je n'ai pas assez joué mais
elle a plus d'expérience après où il fan
aurait pu faire ça parce qu'elle a
l'expérience du haut niveau le problème
c'est que une connexion en bois et et
pas du tout l'habitude de jeux sur
internet et ça s'est vu au début si la
condition durer encore un mois qu'elle
serait ce serait chélifiens ratant
mathieu je vois attend excuse moi de te
couper vrai que j'ai un petit j'ai un
petit j'ai un petit soucis en fait j'ai
été déconnecté de chasse comme c'est
pour ça que je réussissais pas à suivre
à suivre les joueuses on voit de le
match a commencé a commencé mais mais on
a raté le thrips mathieu support bas il
ya 2 il ya deux heures et demie de match
bien à 3h30 match 3 3 me mathieu croizet
suez qui commence à dire j'ai pas j'ai
dit à dd que c'était deux heures et
demie je pense que je lui dise ne leur
seront pas très bien mais je me disais
aussi je n'arrive pas je n'arrive pas à
suivre à suivre les jouets ce qui se
passait en fait c'était c'était de ma
faute alors attends l'échiquier on voit
pas encore
et voilà je vais leur mettre en violet
parce que c'est la couleur du speech à
soissons haletant on a le temps va pas
ce qu'on rate maintenant c'est une
petrov en dessous ou là sa fille qu
hatem pas trop le violet sata sommes
appliqués
ça t'a fait mal et c'est pas un choix
absurde parce que kosteniuk a jamais
obtenu grand chose contre contre un
groupe est contraint de pirey mais
connue qui joue très vite en jeu et
s'est ouverte sur ses positions là c'est
vraiment égalé galles où il ya moyen de
de bosser quand même nom il ya sûrement
une bo ces messages étaient entendus
dans un live tu disais que ça rassemble
les français ne change c'est exactement
ça face à la même structure et en valais
les noirs doivent faire un peu le dos
rond quelques fous mais après ça doit
aller genre là par exemple si tu arrives
à jouer d'amener cette foule bouger et
changer les tourtes à plus de problèmes
auxquels est qu'au juste trouver comment
il faut le faire c'est cette food et si
ce genre par exemple il ya près d'un an
mené cet art a juste le petit problème
de la tour e 8 wells 6 tonnes il est
pathétique
si je pensais un coup aussi bref si ce
doit être un parce qu'après du port de
matane qui peut changer une tour au
matin caillan 17 alors je juste vérifier
une petite chose mathieu marché des
micro interférences sur sur le sur le
son mais à mais c'est possible que ce
soit moi en fait parce que c'est
possible ça vienne c'est largement
possible celle de mes écouteurs donc
j'aurai juste vérifier puisque il me
semble ça doit venir avec skype juste la
petite question au chat nous sarah ok
donc c'est bon y'a aucun il ya aucun
souci mathieu donc on est bon alors là
il ya peut-être des petites masses
tactiquement mathieu je les ai pas vus
ouais mais je vous disais il vise à vie
ouais mais je vous prends 5 c'est pas
bête le jeu d'alger 6 les maîtres un
cavalier en russie et je pense pas que
les blancs réa c'est avec la casse et 5
pour le king baisse note
quelle heure je compte chez lattès arrêt
changer changer les dames tout est
changé et qu'elle réussisse pour éviter
qu'un essai 5 kw améliorait peut-être le
quatrième vl qui peut arriver mathieu
insulaires les plus dangereux
en finale il peut être très fort un
camélia sans qu'un plan b 4 tu fixes une
structure oui puisque tu t'attaques
rêver cet exercice mais tu sais que moi
je commence à être aussi à m je pense
qu'aux riches américains craignant aussi
je commence à préférer les noirs mais en
fait
du coup j'ai pas mal regardé les parties
de hô chi minh ha et dans le milieu de
jeu est là une phase de la partie où
elle joue genres les plus en un tout
petit peu moins bien tu passeras pas la
marque on saura les combis dames 1
des procès cas des gamines à l'accepter
elle est juste super bien et je assez 8
elle arrive à résoudre les problèmes
assez facilement et à la joue et simple
qui avait lui aussi serein alors par
contre dans les finales technique pure
les deux elles ont montré qu'elles
pouvaient avoir des failles après c'est
du militant technique technique pure oui
mais c'est vrai que ces phases de milieu
de jeu entrée de finale et touché n'est
allé à paris pour tellement forte ouais
elle a été un événement assez
impressionnant parce que même sous
pression à s'en sortir ça c'est donc à
quoi elle prend les cases avait sans
doute ramener le roi près c'est quand
même bien mieux mais bon peut-être se
situe à jos et 5 des cats faut rappeler
car a quand même été championne du monde
ou chez nina à win or j'en suis sûr
parce que à mustapha elle n'a pas peur
elle a perdu comme aux idiots que nous
ou alors la gagne à la l1 s'est qualifié
pour la finale élite iv à la peut-être
perdu la finale
- la période finale mais non mais les
deux d'ailleurs été géniaux qui a été
championne du monde ça j'en suis sûr à
100% on met les deux montées cheveux du
monde on va dire ça t'aide les jaunes en
chat peuvent nous dire le chat je les
pages l'est pas on va voir qui est qui
pour les pseudos thiès queen s'est
colleté nu oui et haine qui sait où chez
nina après on a fait les choses bien tu
vois j'ai mis on sera toujours côté du
les visages seront toujours du bon côté
quoi le live du monde 2012 2016 vous
chercheriez monde en 2012
championne du monde 2007 2016 moi ça me
dit largement quelque chose parce que je
me rappelle avoir été à moscou qui a une
soirée organisée pour son titre je me
rappelle d'un truc comme ça et d'avoir
été invités à cette soirée dont elle a
gagné la coupe du monde
non c'est là les troupes du monde je
suis d'accord ah oui c'est la coupe du
monde alors mais tu vois le problème
c'est qu'il ya tellement d'appellations
différentes qui se ressemblent c'est la
coupe du monde c'est connu mon enquête
je suis d'accord et coupe du monde
c'était pas un titre de championne du
monde
oui oui et non mais après un match aller
perdu tôt c'est sur ce truc
d'appellation tu sait jamais vraiment
qui a gagné quoi tous les noirs
commencent à être mieux à un moment je
peux faire c'est 4 sûr que des cas tu
peux prendre écrit un pion passé
et sinon genre baies 5 pouces et sinon
tu es cas et ses cinq avocats tout cas
l'idée trois ans il faut passer à payer
de plus tôt vous avez d'ailleurs pu dire
et ses singles et là on peut commencer à
discuter on a des cases
puis commence à être cool hein surtout
que le roi il commença à ta tâche à deux
pions je sais pas ce que je sais pas si
tous rage suite était un détour des 85
j'élève gfk 6,7
ouais ça c'est votre main elle a perdu
trop de temps au kef ou encore jeux pour
des cas tu comprends tout reprend jusque
là nous vers ici c4 avait peut-être g6
j'ai vu mertens commente rémi rtas
commente henri soyez très chaud et
d'être costaud mais alors il fait pas le
truc officiel il se fait un truc de son
côté quoi ah ok il est très heureux
enfin il est très tôt je suis en train
de me récupérer mathieu tu vois obligé
de trucs sur l'écran le petit truc pour
pas perdre le elle a pas joué des cats
et un peu passive elle a dans ce sens
par an dont il ya un truc bon c'est que
le début on peut en discuter je vois pas
le temps en bas c'est assez énervant je
vois que le temps du haut à wes pas déjà
la fois sur ton partage d'écran scarlett
qui avait un truc qui était malsain tue
mais on avait réussi ou weight avait
réussi jeu puisque tu avais fait en tout
cas je peux dire qu'il ya plus qu 2003
avec les blancs avec les noirs pardon et
donc elle est assez normal elle est mal
an maintenant chez nous bah ouais ben
quand tu fais pas des cats ou là tous
les jours à 8 ça c'est un mystique
ouais bah d'ailleurs au cas de cette
unité pub c'est terrible s'était achevée
je peux me débrouiller pour que tu as un
peu les calmes
comment j'avais fait un allin fois pour
enlever ça c'est terrible
c'est terrible pour mathieu alors j'ai
trouvé un truc c'est ok najjar et
d'avoir le temps
bon ok c'est super mais par contre des
coups je vois notre conversation entre
qui savent rien du coup mathieu et je
vais avoir l'option passé hl1 mais ça ne
marche tout cochet nina qui grimace mais
allegri va se jouer ça marche chez qui
suppose assez bien je reprendrai obligé
de prendre un gîte en gîte cet électorat
le fuit trouve ça hyper logique un mois
j'aurais fait pareil mais pourquoi l'a
fait elle si ce n était mieux tant mieux
mais un peu son jeu fait de torbay road
again the taux rapide prend la connaît
bizarre un nom après c'est vrai que
c'est si ça gagne en force mais du coup
c'est le genre de truc tu peux perdre
une minute et se repeint minor cavaliers
par où il passe alors a pu repasser par
ab 5 à part lever 5 au mental tu touches
et le pion mais bon c'est pas l'embellie
ça tu passais toutes mes qualités 6,3 et
6,6 sa fille faire peur car la 3g c'est
toi servent surtout à faire c'est une
cavale de huit des fois tu peux avoir
des repères tout cas vis aux quatre
carrés lieu de quatre comme ça tu
récupères c3 du coup de tête tour h33
ses fins je pense à k et v3 pour se
venger sur ses seins et amical a lieu
quatre d'un roi des six noms rôle 5%
byron à rolle 5 direct pas qu'on a c'est
pas mal plus on prend puis on prend roi
prend 3,6 temps reprend cavaliers f5
pour chatou mais est-ce que je peux pas
jouer kébé 3d 3d 3 c'est clair kéhi c5
on voit ces 6 rapp rendait
je pense je trouve qu'elle se bat hyper
bien dans cette phase où il y en a
beaucoup qui auraient perdu rapide elle
a très bien joué là qu'est kf5 malin
peut-être j'ai pas je préfère à cavalia
vii
j ai pas pensé non non moi non plus mais
j'trouve ça change la vue la case tu
vois ce que tu t'en jusqu'à un piège
leur tour f1 qui avait lieu 3g pas genre
tu vas peut-être faire tour un roi 17
tours f1 et tu prends qu'elle prendra
tournons tous revenir face on prend pas
du cavalier tu vas être cloué à inviter
les sauvegardes pour la chaîne qui fait
que nature à jeter un objet de faire
cavalier prend et tu feras tourache 8k
relief 7
après faut pas oublier un tour cavaliers
contours ce nul donc même si le cavalier
attaque bateaux sont à la bouffe et le
purin et d'heure c'est assez facile je
les fais ya pas longtemps au blitz le en
3 + 1 le tour cavaliers contre tours et
honnêtement j'ai fait hyper facilement
elle met du coup de calais prend obligé
donc il ajouté vie 3 cc3v cet endroit
c'est cette impression assez cavalli il
faut juste aller chercher le répit en
plus je fais retour à schwyz tour des
tchèques moi ouais ce que j'ai au
khalife 7 un bon entourage qui dans tous
les cas c'est obliger ses fins c'est le
tour à la fin 2007 est maintenant voilà
c'est nul maintenant nul face in this
way ça a bien défendu
[Musique]
un scénario assez prévisible
j'aurais fait kébé 16 pareil jolie
partie mathieu
ouais pourquoi j'étais sérère des
connexions wi donc en fait
ouverture rien spéciale puis à prendre
l'avantagé avec le noir du trot passible
ça je les ai vus dans quelques parties
d'étoilés trop passive et parents
défunts hyper bien quand elle est sous
pression alors du coup le west end à
table elle a préparé une ninja elle doit
pas jouer son monde à lui apparaît son
endroit après continue que j'ai toujours
trouvé quel jeu des petites lignes pas
forcément très bonne sur des cats avec
les garçons le stand l'autre jour elle
était un peu chez qui chez qui je suis
quand même surpris mathieu dans le sens
où on chez nina elle était tellement
forte avec les blancs dans ce tournoi
elle a fait tellement mal avec le
système de longues que je m'attendais
l'avoir essayé de mettre en place le
système de londres puis éventuellement
de tester à prévoir contre sara par
exemple la position qu'a sa race et
justes ne peut faire un nul en un coup
dans l'ouverture leurs forces mais ça
m'a rendu fou si les trois fois la
partie l1 à guînes une et perdu 2 mais
juste il ya un an elle joue un coup la
fil rouge ou pas la ligne mais bon après
ça prouve bien que sera ne trichez pas
elise est pas les messages entre les
parties alors on a eu droit de lire les
messages entre les parties ou pas je
pense pas à la pause à la pause car il
est à 4 être malin ça c'est un peu ça
peut enfermer le toit et moi même mais
ces cinq c'est bien jusqu'où non tu peux
mais le fou et tour bergues en fait
seront ceux de l'eau d'ailleurs je sais
que ça marche pas beaucoup pourquoi faut
4 un voeu gaz mais en fait elle a un
répertoire assez malin à thiès queen
mais dans les gros tournois là des
grosses près fort mais sinon c'est
souvent des petites lignes de tri glover
qui sont souvent malin j'aurais joue
plus une position de structures qu'une
ligne concrète avec les noirs jamais ce
qu'ils en oublient c'est parfait mais il
ça peut mal se passer l'exemple la
partie qu'on a commenté le total entre
contrat ce qu'objectivement c'est pas la
meilleure
et là par exemple salines et la
jouabilité ce qui l'est c'est solide
quand les blancs font un peu n'importe
un des blancs en fait ont dû jouer pour
sortir leurs pièces en trop cherché à
réfuter
mais du coup les noirs sont ok c'est
pour ça que c'est très bien et c'est
jamais facile a réfuté ces petites
variantes de façon en lice la kabylie à
quatre c'est plus un coup jolie que bon
friis que j'allais dire le cas elle est
mal placée fin maxime me serais très
heureux de ce coup mais oui mais qui a
laissé 3 c'est logique après le tumulte
et b5
donc ils tuent doperont et qui arrive et
qu'elle provoqua procès oui oui non mais
du coup je vais vous prendre ces trois
doit être forcé et surprend plus tôt 2b
où la dame dame tu t'habilles mme
parisot en gros sans réfléchir
j'aurais fait pareil mais je voulais
vérifier non parce que j'aurai ckt
beaucoup trop faible et en fait ton seul
tu as eu l'idée ce serait de jouer avec
le karaté mais t'as pas le temps mais
l'art est du coup je pense que les noirs
ont une compression normal avec beaucoup
de temps d' avance après les blancs bon
jeu b3 foulée 2-1 à quai le long de la
longue diagonale bas ils doivent se sent
15,91 peu pressée 5 et b3 mais me
changera jeu des trônes ce que puis on
prend des cadres se présente ça va nous
soulager mais c'est pas sûr à 100% ça
dépend si on se prend un b 5 ou un
dessin à d'ailleurs c'est peut-être une
vraie idée des cinq ans on a tellement
de retard développement des cinq c'est
vrai que ça mais j'ai il ya aucune prise
qui donne envie en ce qu'il reprenne un
cavalier ou même de la dame en ce sens
qu'on fera pression pour prendre une
fois elle prend de la dame on va dire
peut-être font les trois dames c'est
cette affaire contre 206 codes même
c'est un peu dégueulasse comme ça je
prends c'est catherine better way il
faut l'essayer en fait de pas reprendre
faire dans des cas précis je rentre je
ne serai jamais marché non ça n'a jamais
marché
on va voir ce qu'elle a fait dans la
partie à la fédé 8 à la paf et c500 b2b
cette cavalière donc là les bleus l'ont
sont à deux doigts d'être un peu mieux
mais pas encore ça détend aussi des cinq
baies 5 marche
l'avion des cinq dernières
en fait elle n'a pas le temps c'est
rêver le temps de faire f trois ou
quatre des cinq rebelles seraient
gagnantes mais f3 tu vas angers 6 potter
est en train de me dire ayant 6 6 je
peux peut-être ainsi qu'à la priver
sakaris que tu prends je donne tu prends
mais chacun s'attaque 2 lennon bon jeu
sur carte blanche tient qu'à ses saints
et la case the cat il y avait trop de
faibles je préfère le noir ils ont une
énorme masse centrale entre les
cavaliers qui peuvent réagir au centre
et les pions qui sont majoritaires au
centre les north a l'impression qui
domine ya la tour c 8 qui est bien placé
et finalement four b2 dame c3 ça réussit
pas trois jeux contes g7 à cause du
cavalier quoi donc à y aller car elle y
eu quatre ou six qui rôde mais bon elle
va je pense à vous chez nina faire
comment la partie d'avant robuste
robusto ou robusta peut-être plus tôt m
oui mais pour l'instant on se fait
dominer vie oui légèrement messi a
réussi à tirer une deuxième nul tu vois
tu as été deux fois mardi fait deux nuls
je prendrai les tours b 8 ou c4 vous
tombez 8 j'aime pas le truc c'est que tu
peux prendre prendre le décrire b4 à
faire du 26 mai c'est fou de torbay but
elles font des coups un peu trop mou de
choix attention quand les français force
et moi j'aurais fait b4 je ne serais pas
allé prendre directement j'aurais fait
payer 4000 à tours en c1 paca et 17
yapaka et 17 dans laquelle sept
étrangers si c'est oui c'est pour ça
j'ai pu donc ben et moi mais bon pour
moi ça a du sens stratégique de faire ça
et après de phoebé 4000 calories façon
elle va faire cavalier à 4 hors effet
tout problème si c'est pareil
donc j'étais alors ça va transposer un
oui parce que kelly 7 s'est toujours pas
un coût et donc ça transposant vrai
juste ulas plus d'options mais est-ce
que kébé 7 qui avait des cariocas ricard
a lieu quatre tours c'est un état tu
fais trois ou quatre avec simplement un
wave 3 du beau monde au qatar mais juste
à faire il faut trouver quoi faire trop
cavalier peut-être le matin en g2 je
pense que c'est un tour ça c'est au tour
6 1 à 5
peut-être cavaliers venant ici
mais moi j'aurais pas aimé laisser les
trucs accueille ces trois tondus de
genre effet tour c'est injuste parce que
ça me saoule est ce que tu peux essayer
d'organiser genre prisé un tour c'est 4
ou 1 to retour de lancer dans cette
galère fait autour des 4 tout de suite
comme ça qui donne pas la casse est ce
un retour des cadres direct essayer de
choses à la d5
pourtant ça si je n'aime pas trop parce
que des cinq façons c'est elle alors
voulez vous aillez le jeu à 4 4 et 4
ouais mais je pense qu'elle a oublié des
quatre cavalières 4 et bien tenir
d'abord fait carrière kat d'abord qui
menace pesait 2 4 et sur des 4 3 aux
caïds et trois blocs heures à venir
après le cadre des 4 6 4 enfin en moins
bons cavaliers pour aller en d3 - des f3
pantxika annuel à 3 est pas encore
comprise s'est pas fait encore pour
celles frêle 3
je n'aurais pas trop je cette position
avec les blancs je te dis tout de suite
oui on est un peu moins bien sans
remonte beaucoup de jeu donc ça ça
menace rien mais c'est si un jour tu
arrives à faire sur ces 7 août vers
cette horde équipe réussisse ouais il ya
lesquelles chacun soit limite toi il ya
plus de chance d' arnaque à la côte et
blancs les noirs sont mieux est à plus
de chance en essayant de la gagner de
sortir de piste avec les noirs je suis
d'accord avec toi mais c'est vrai parce
que le roi est plus faible sans que nous
ouais après normalement naissance et
préférez les mains parce que à 3 peut
tomber je dis pas qui va tomber mais il
peut pas vraiment on peut faire une
mineure qui a eu quatre cadets 6/4 6/4
donc ça parle ça c'est pour se mettre
dans un cas elle prend 2,6 un jour
d'ailleurs parlant de ça suffit de
bouger le cavalier hacker prend aussi sa
tour c'est un mono de gagner juste
peut-être ça et menacerait hillyer tour
des 7 je peux jouer les points 6 pions
tron est prise prise tomber cette finul
tu peux jouer pas pour gagner mais pour
annuler sa marche mais tu sais que je
commence vraiment regardé fut d'accord
avec toi les blancs les blancs sont
objectivement un peu moins bien mais
près d'un point de vue pratique qui sont
mieux mais toujours un g8 trois buts
mais d'avoir une fille zohra g7 regarde
le temps ouais se retrouve mal autant je
pense se faire broyer fuite est belle
elle défend bien comme ce pragmatique
les deux dames 1 mais du coup cavaler h
5 mai - 5 qu'est ce que t'es content de
force sur le faire peut-être doit
commencer par g4 mais c'est un peu
artistique stop est ce que j'ai 4 3 3
avec deux équipes
j'aime bien c'est peut-être un jour tu
as même ce plan là en finale c'était
calme finale déjà avec le roi qui monte
c'est pas une fan de rubinstein ça chez
moi je me rappelle jamais de nom d'un
autre comme dit monsieur cissé souffle
yves de pub et bissett qu'elle 5 et le
jeu ça c'est louche elle va faire plutôt
gênés 3 kgs ces cinq points du tout kébé
trois des six québec at aider 3par est
bon coin un caïd et 3 mai à ce qu'il
sait 5 donc sirois des six québec at on
prend 1,3 qualifié six des huit ans
prend sa seule crainte c'est que la
qualité non ouais on va prendre est
s'alarmer d'une qualité 3-3 à l'envi en
plus à la tête pas vu le coup ainsi six
ya le jour
c'est logique trois des six pour moi
c'est fort ce que c'est son gameplay
kébé 4g jours et relie québec est il ya
aussi à quatre avec l'idée tour prends
ton temps 17 10 à 4
mais je pense que bkc le couple torride
jouer à trois casses ici ce qu'est ce
qu'on a loupé à tour ses 5,1 bien je
sais bien et non le pion à peu devenir
une force toi ma belle roi noir est bien
placé c'est loin
ouais je suis victime personne
probablement dont g 8 h 5 1 mais je h3
f3 au caire que ça rassure à la pendule
un 3e à la pendule continue qui est
largement mis au moins y'a pas photo car
on l a été accueilli des trois tours 7
elle a été à la pas été mauvaise et où
chez nina c'est chan ok maintenant les
blancs doivent être objectivement mieux
mais c'est les noirs qu'on plus de temps
et les pions passé le cavalier actifs à
l'aller nord ont gagné dans la manche on
pense aux échecs à le faire qu'est le
trou toro 6 très bien joué elle bloque
et bloque les deux pions là et là il n'y
a pas de match ça peut rendre fou ça
même si c'est pas sûr sur les noirs et
les blancs les noirs ont fait en sorte
de pas pousser mais peuvent plus pousser
leurs pions la carène à karaj f53 cinq
cavaliers 7 c'est pas sûr que tu reste
l'option après ou la voilà ça c'est
terrible mais qui chez qui la bat 4
secondes on va pas se mentir on serait
pas plus ridicule ou pas - je dirais
plutôt où il a eu 2 ou là c'est terrible
soit six matches ces équipes on n'est
pas trop sauf à essars épais de la
petrov mais tu vois même même même sur
l'emballement final là je suis pas sûr
que kosteniuk soit vraiment plus fort
plus fortin la soute shibam avait l'air
plus forte mais une pièce je me trouve
c'était c'était très très chaud en tout
cas c'est reparti en fait tout est roi
c'est connu salon des 5 juste un cran du
15 au 20 mai
c'est un genre de grandes variantes non
ça ouais c'est pas la plus grande mais
oui ça lisent un cahier 5 et après les
nombreux à 4-4 ça mais non c'est plutôt
une thune souligner est en fait la
grande question c'est est ce qu'on
arrive à stabiliser les cases blanches
sont en bouffant des trois genres faire
justice ferait 5 h c est ce qu on arrive
à bien me faire engrosser la question
parce que t'as pas envie de te prendre
f5 dans la gueule quoi
mais il ya de la ressource pour un petit
peu je fous trois cavaliers ou deux
matins cavaliers sur des cas tout g3 et
pousser m 5 en force c'est qu'elle est
en train de faire il devra être partie
de kram nick nom comme ça avec les noirs
dans des idées des vieilles mais en fait
ça c'est des mecs home depot ils ont
remis un jour un peu ce système mais
objectivement moyenne mais j'ai toujours
pensé que ça c'est des gâchis mort qui
était le spécialiste des blancs le
premier question a fait un gros joueur
[Musique]
c'est c'est louche
mais est-ce qu'on peut jeu de dames b6
feu trois dames bekkat pour taper ces 2
et pourrait changer d'âme
ouais l'autre chose c'est en la faveur
des normands d'échangé d'armes dans
cette position là au moins tu te rend
plus des attaques sur le roi et ses
trois cahiers d icade on se dote
également d'un croc le cas en deux mois
je prends les noirs mais bon tout en
sachant que tu pas mieux mais plus bas
après tu peux pas vraiment est moins
bien trop bien tu fais pousser 5
reprendre le tchad oui la fête à mme b 6
mai à surfer ou trois bleus non mais moi
ce n'est pas ces cinq ou six que mon
coup mais franchement non même si ça
marche le envie de dire non ça me paraît
dangereux l'info f2 des quatre étapes à
une pièce de sortie c'est un truc
d'orgies ça j'ai passé trois têtes du
coup ces deux blocs ou dérange pas aves
elles paraissent trop dangereux alors
mesdames b4 oui c'est logique c'est
logique ça c'est la bonne nouvelle c'est
quoi
s'il dit ouais moi j'ai tendance à
penser que ça va pour tout le monde
toi il n'est pas impressionnant tant sur
cnn g3 pas mal ça empêche fou 4 non mais
par exemple le recul mais même le léger
joan j'allais dire même même un coup
comme alors je voulais dire grand roque
mais j'imagine français à ne pas laisser
mes à 5 à 6 à 5 kw est car il est par
ailleurs cinq pions prends je crois 17
et j'aurais pas je vois pas où est le
problème pour les noirs ici mais je
positionne à pas ces lampes ce que c'est
des pions doublé isolé qui devraient
très mauvais mais ici sont bien bien
soutenue par le roi ils prennent de
l'espace mais le seul façon d'attaquer
si une tournée en chine adhère laférois
17 est rempli on prend un tour ici roi
des rois de la 3d 5 et 5 t'empêche
éclaté après tu pousses un mais parce
que j'ai l'impression de regarder un
quatre contre trois là je vais mettre
tous les tyrans rouge et du coup le
cadre compte et c'est un quatre contre
trois assez stérile et j'ai l'impression
que les noirs le pion passé peut se
dessiner assez facilement et en rien les
pions sont soit caucase - donc le flou
et 7 peut un jour de faire une tôle
échiquier été grattée pourquoi la
majorité plus mobile d'un pour les noirs
et les blancs fait h3g cat est pas
vraiment un plan qui selon le roi
derrière oui avantage ou du mauvais côté
je vais te dire elle aurait pu jouer b
5a 5b 4 mais d'un autre côté elle veut
tout rejet quatre tours g8 pas si con
c'est papa tu peux mettre un flash car
tu peux faire un truc défunt fou des
huîtres ou b6 un jour je bats sa gaffe
aux cures 1,7 moi je leur ai pas laissé
ben j'avais bien faire b 5 à 5 façons ça
mange pas de pain et garder plus de
flexibilité avec les tours des deux
côtés et prend la décision après de quel
côté tu navigues inquiète les blancs
c'est chez sprint et costinha quelqu'un
demande
c'est bizarre moi et danser les caméras
sont du bon côté mais ça c'est vrai que
les noms sur un peu petit sur czech
comme si vous regardez d'un téléphone
mobile
est ce que 4h trois ce serait con
possible non après peut-être un jour
mais libre et je joue vraiment trop
c'est pas le bon côté mais l'homme moi
je pars et c4 c4 ces mamans une menace
là maintenant oui ouais le truc c'est
que ok tu vas réussir à faire h3 mettant
a perdu tellement de temps pour faire ça
tu te fais contre et de l'autre côté je
pense qu'elle veut faire puis on prend
ce but là c'est une petite faille
stratégie c'est rien c'est vraiment
ridicule 1 à la can perdue 1 2 3 4
on va dire quatre coups parce que
l'autre a dû au froid et faim elle a
perdu quatre coups pour jouer ce plan là
qui apporte rien en vrai et pourquoi je
peux pop un hic quand je peux pas
prendre la septième g3 qui tombe mais
est tombée trois gagnées pas un clan
juste peut-être ouais tout cas là je
pense tour g8 doit être un coup c'est
touran me paraît tellement mal placé
mathieu manger 4 et de 6 pour reprendre
du fou bref si ceci possible à melo n'a
souvent un set peut-être plus mais pour
ça il assiste au total cost si je pense
égaliser on prend prix souvent à sat2way
mais je voulais faire tour b4g pas lui
mais gm et saab c'est un ouais ouais
et du coup tombée c'est tu te venge sur
sur f 4l a fait à six mais je peux
comprendre d'après tour des caf ou 7 on
contrôle la casse des six donc la
taurine jamais on n'y a pas de c'est une
bonne égalité dans les noirs ont freiné
le passé mais juste en fait nombre
d'ambitions tout comme dans la première
wii qui manque d'ambition avec les mains
ouais c'est terrible après on va ouvrir
à kaunas il ya tellement con ce nom
c'est les blancs qu'ils ont je préfère
quand même légèrement les blancs je sais
pas j'ai l'impression qu'un jour tu as
aussi des plans après trois peut-être g4
moi j'ai plus peur de tours à shatura
chitou rachad
mais mon petit tu mets ta tours angers 8
le roi des singes
ça peut être beau signe fort st n'oublie
pas il ya toujours trois contre deux
mais maintenant la tête recommence à
l'envoyer justement faire ces cinq baies
5 c 4
kerouay f3 ici ma jun mais avec vraiment
stratégiquement pas très bien joué il
faut le dire avec les noirs parce que
c'est vrai que b 5 à 5 tu joue aux
échecs quand même joué du côté de sa
majorité c'est un conseil après livre
sur la table de minorité qui a fait du
mal à ce concept
c'est vrai aussi mais on est quand même
d'accord que la plupart du temps il y
avait quelque chose j'avais déjà raconté
sur la chaîne ne sais pas si je peux le
répéter un hymne à 3h30 live dans le
livre game change je suis pas si tu l'as
vu il ya ils ont fait des statistiques
sur des positions où il ya une attaque
de minorités possible entre à 9,01
stockfisch ya eu le cas où alpha 0 fait
une attaque d'humanité ces genres 1 sur
10 allez dans les cases vote ouais c'est
très rare bah c'est pas lui le fait
chaud et stockfisch déjà c'est peu mais
j'adore c'était deux ou trois mais oui
nationaux
la structure bad c'est surtout la pousse
au centre qui est pénible
non mais souvent c'est les positions
figées et attaquer les droits non voilà
c'est quand même bien les gains même
elles vont pas faire ne le sache je le
dis tout de suite
généralement dans cette compétition ça
jours d'ailleurs c'est le gros point
fort de cette compétition je trouvais
meilleur d'eux mêmes quand il leur
restait deux secondes
ferrero jouer une partie à fond vous est
pas venu on va pas se mentir c'est une
belle compétition en réalité c'est juste
qu'ils ont fait un format tellement
l'ont finalement que
massa a passé d'un truc sympa un trucs
relou en fait ils ont eu la chance qu'il
en jeu jusqu'au bout
oui ah oui j'aime beaucoup de chance par
un peu où nina gagne son 2e tour c'est
fini il est à deux jours de commentaires
commentaires complètement inutile mais
même mais même comme ça c'était c'était
trop mathieu quatre semaines nous nous
sommes franchement vu que oui ça peut
faire mieux avec cinq tours h5 c'est
assez logique mais fahrenheit for five
one après dans cette compétition
généralement les filles elles veulent
jamais faire nul hein c'est
impressionnant
les petites qui est plus un terminal
pour 16,6 à la fois 5e four au sort il
ya pas de raison ou bien tout cas elle
réfléchit aux côtés du faut faire gaffe
un parfois quand tu penses que tu as un
peu mieux que tu réfléchis trop pour
essayer de gagner tu te mets ma l'otan
et après l'autre il essaye de te battre
et tu peux donc du coup issifou faire
guère qu'un amoureux katell 520 quelque
chose peut-être mais le future c3 pour
défendre b 2 est le jeu f5 et que ce
soit protégé non mais ce qu'on peut
faire
les échecs ou un en fait c'est pas
besoin de faire plusieurs tons pépin et
sur war3 tu fais quoi
mais le menacerons fkm juin coup sûr il
faut un coup c'est guette
ça c'est bizarre mais ça du ce même
allons tomber un jeu commence à tomber 8
mai tombent une fois cette houle un v6
est la panique est bon sauf bayrou ainsi
sympa donc tour g7 va jouer non plus un
tour en jeu celle passe constructeurs et
si ça devrait quand même fait un nul
assez facile on peut pas les recettes y
attendait 6 donc on doit aller là bas si
sûrement mal tous les blancs gagny ok
tomber deux j'aime bien
elle veut pas elle peut pas défendre
passivement est du coup assez bien joué
parce que son groupe b 2 des fonds peut
redonner la tour rouge le pion f et
pousser nos pions je vais même vous fait
les deux et à revenir
balla tomb raider je pense sûrement
hésiter après ça a du sens dans l'absolu
ce qu'elle a fait ça c'est intéressant
d'expliquer elle préfère donner un pion
à que le plomber même au prix d'un temps
parce que les pions sont plus durs à
pousser et qui ont passé 5 pour faire
nul peut-être n'ont ainsi ses katas
mener le jeu pour nul nous ça c'est trop
risqué
est ce qu a fait le tour f6 menaces tout
rêve si ça va perdre ouais j'ai annoncé
que les blancs gagner rien c'est bizarre
de vouloir tout le temps je vais pour
gagner quand même ben ouais c'est
terrible le mondial c'est qu'elle a
perdu non non c'est du monde so close un
temps près ouais alors ça elle a perdu à
sonner le tocsin de besoin ouais après
l'était pas si facile que ça mais cette
attente est donc toi et répète
et pourtant elle était un peu moins bien
bâle un partout pour moi ça c'est un
gros impact psychologique ce début de
match parce que les partis sont
tellement cher est tellement dur à
gagner pour les deux joueuses de
démarrer comme ça avec un 2 0 ça fait
quand même très mal surtout il y avait
il n'y a pas de raison oui les noms mais
il répète elle répète sans réfléchir
dame ce2 elle réfléchit un peu
elle rejoue le même plan qui lui donne
une position un peu inférieur bah c'est
pas ce que j'appelle une bonne action on
est d'accord
ouais là non ça joue pas mal aimé par
contre ça craque quand il reste cinq
secondes mais l'on b3 et signé par mois
elle peut à peu près temps avant un
petit plus un jour mais c'est toujours
pareil mathieu quand tu compare avec le
top niveau
xts ça fait une différence mais mes
grands maîtres à kg 5 c'est du classique
ça m'a aidé de aussi d'ailleurs et à
kenzo qui prend des deux il y avait la
tour eiffel en l'air mais peut-être qu'à
jacques et g5 quoi qu'il en soit indemne
7,7 fois tout à l'heure j'ai attaqué au
calme mais peut-être qu'à vidéo choc du
coup c'est un beau bonjour dessinera
liorel vous jouez le jeu pour f3 non
mais les blancs sont mieux par un jeu
très agréable wildcat f5 pour moi je
prends juste ce n'est pas le bon plan
poids non c'est plutôt je reçois sont
donc tu disais quoi par rapport au top
niveau une armée c'est juste c'est pas
une question de filles bien ses
négations et joue à l'autre oui parce
que je sais ce que j'ai ce que je sais
là où je voulais en venir mathieu veut
dire qu'elles ont un niveau de grand
maître
je suis m je suis pas beaucoup de vent a
bien que j'ai perdu pas mal de prendre
mais j'ai continué qu'elle a peut-être
plus comment mon nom je suis pas sur moi
mais ouais mais c'est ça c'est niveau
grand maître c'est pas top mondial quoi
ces niveaux grand maître si côté nuggets
la ceinture inscrivait un nom il ya
trois heures et demie de jeu donc s'il
ya vraiment le temps de revenir
oui c'est pas comme dans les autres
speech est sans fin comme pendant les
grands prix où ça a joué 30 minutes 30
minutes et dix minutes là s'ajoutent 90
60 et 30
même à 4 points d'écart vu à quel point
les niveaux sont serrés ça peut revenir
oui puisqu'il a le score honnêtement
reflète pas du tout la peau la dernière
partie c'était ok coating domine un peu
mais après se retrouver en finale comme
moins qu'elle gagne parce que je ne veux
pas faire nul d'hambourg pour moi
pour moi le score logique serait
vraiment égalité jusqu'ici on va
peut-être plus un cousin kosteniuk
vendanges dos quand même dans le dos
mais non les blancs sont un peu bien ça
n'appartient pas la position auquel a
stratégiquement et peut-être du jouable
à quatre avec l'idée bekkat b5
ça c'est une vraie idée stratégique qui
ne doit pas marcher ici puisque c'est
cette reine mais ça c'est bien je sais
ce que tu peux faire a cédé 5 arrêts
alliés prg en russie c'est bien simple
et on regarde la wii non mais si tu
prépares avec ton rêve d un ben oui mais
même pourquoi pas de dessin juste non
mais là les collages et hyper bizarre
non pour ses 8 balles et en fait son
idée c'est que ce soit un dessin à la
fin il ya c'est cette quête
mais là ici tu peux jouer f3 hkd des
cinq pattes a tellement de coups qu'on a
l'air bon est ce que tu peux jouer tous
rêvent d un retour à dire mais je ne
serais pas surpris si un truc direct ici
bon moi un vrai créneau à 4 des 5 mais
je pense à doit pas marcher a que deux
des cinq space mountain dont elle se
fait complètement dominés dans cette
phase de jeu mais je vole même temps hk
j'étais en train de me demander mais
j'étais sûr hk peut-être qu'à le faire
des 5
ouais mais l'on comprend que je prends
un caïd et 3 celle là je vais te la
jouer un sorcier pas besoin de face mais
jean médecin et est ce que tu peux pas
jouer à 4 x 3 on vient pression 1,4
contrôler la casse b5 et tu prépares x 3
tu vas cloud est assis sur un futur
dessin et là je t'empêche tout
contrevenant à la ps3 qui avait cinq
tours fr elle veut jouer pour eux quatre
là c'est bien aussi un don du sang ce du
sens
après je
pour ai pas fait ça mais ça ne veut pas
dire ses pommes
il ya tellement d'options agréable
mathieu pour les blancs trees et f4
yaccarini h3 peut-être ça je veux
revenir au 4 mai joue un pion ça donne
un pion je pense je pensais que j'avais
poussé 6 mais j'ai pas du tout medjani
qui avait les h3 peut-être que j'ai
raison sans fard esprit qui est h 3o
éléphants
il est est en fête dont truc je fais
trop roger 2 ouais mais tu chopes le
cavalry peut-être peut-être c'est bien
elle a fait craquer h5 damage cinq
britanniques avaient lieu 4 milliards et
là je crois qu'ils en repartir en effe
cette belle le fougueux plus entre 6 et
je pense qu'il faut jeu il faut arriver
à jeu 4 ou 10 et surtout des 5 1 pour
que le fouet de vie si les noirs de
l'eiblen d'organes sur les cases noires
ça doit se terminer par un matin j'ai
c'est toujours un truc comme ça
hk l'ajax avait du sens à une idée qui
est maintenant r4 ou et 4 tu sais que ça
ressemble à la vieille partie de stanis
rosenthal c'est nice qui est hyper
connue sur la paire de fou qui domine en
fout cavaliers qui se fait chasser avec
m6 hier par angers 4 il se prend h5 je
pense y repartirait jalil en bouche plus
jamais heureusement un bulletin
mais c'est un moins j'en reviens
j'aurais jamais je sais pas ce que
j'aurais trop peur 4,4 soit fort ici
mais bon peut-être sf4 pour les noirs
ouais voilà pris ben bella du coup je
reprends une pièce la dame n'ont pas
bonne
tu commences à viser aussi ce qui
revient le 6 mai john wayne et tu seras
tu veut peut-être damev cette caméra
c'est faux c'est un choix
vous savez où j'ai 5 c'est bien rires
c'est même très bien joué ouais bien
joué non au caire prend son temps c'est
un peu son défaut mais c'est une bonne
partie et même strate shoah schiste
suivies d'effets 4 c'est un taxi ce long
terme 0 contre je pas de g5 pas de 5 4
des 5 pâtissent après tu remarques
caustiques joue quand même plus vite ça
peut ça peut sur un long match comme ça
surtout avec les cadences qui accélère
être un facteur important
mathieu
elle reviendra f7 ça n'a pas du tout la
wave point info je crois qu'existe le
nom il faut qu'on vous prend j'ai cinq
fois je crois bouger 4 sa part et c'est
sympa en plus tu pouvais forcer les
changes des dames est redoublée encore
les pions c'est pas bête
elle fixe mois fois je crois à fois je
crois mon as touché 4 gagnent la dame en
plus maintenant il faut s en fout des 3b
4 j'aime pas je trouve qu'elle joue un
peu à l'envers un peu comme tout à
l'heure juste à une dame qui en ferme et
à une aile roi en laye âgées g4
d'arâches quatre fous et 3 ok j'en souci
à ce que tu avoueras j'essaie je vais
remettre mon four b2 med - exulte pas si
claire talent et je suis fier de son
aval à la foulée deux tours à je suis 3
m2 sur lequel mieux pour les blancs ses
parents non j'attends quatre tourelles
fille de bush a wife 2 p th 6 encore que
prochain tour h 1 kg 4 roy gère 1 c'est
bien je dois je fous b2 parce que il ya
un g5 qui traîne quand elle joue sa dame
chez dassault à la finale canadienne
droit ou deux pour être sur un perso
ouais il ya des caraïbes 5 de ses 6 peux
tu vraiment une idée un faux f1 bien
jouer sa main
normal menace fou détroit et le roi
pourrait pas rester collés aux cavaliers
au fiancé 6 peut-être mais je te faire
des 5
il faut des trois et non je vais perdre
il faut des trois des cinq poules b 2
thorax fuite
il faut trouver un coup là mathieu pour
pour les sourds à hull et ça peut être
obligés non en fait t'as vraiment un
super g ça tu veux faire kireev 7 à la
rigueur t'as pas envie mais tu peux on
est tu laisseras entraînera un sound
mais là je pense ça perd il ya des 500
gagne 7,7 et puis on prend bien on prend
il faut re bouge pas je vais food et
trois poubelles encore plus fort mais
j'ai gagné le cavalier h61 ça serait
bien que pour le match qu'est le trou il
faudrait 3 et ça marche aussi je pense
et des cinq ans donc en fait là
concrètement amena ceux qui ont bien
plus grands gestes les fouets et foulée
2 n'en fut médaillé aux 5
oui bah oui du coup sa part oui mais ce
que verse que sur foot et au kef au
bessat du couffo pranger sacré tu peux
tout échanger bufeo 6 6 3 de suite bon
alors elle va faire peut-être qu'à
rallier f5 qui est le 5e 7e je peux
prendre eux aussi n'est pas de
découverte fait qu'à jean iv roeder être
très vraisemblablement bien se venger de
aussi par principe tu préfères redonnant
allongé 2 peu importe la tourache 7
c'est sûr et toi et toi chien il faut
voir si tu as des maths tout rouge fatal
à l'autriche annonce qu'elle va prendre
ouais mais tu en c4 mais français qu'à
dessin mural abandonne je pensais
qu'elles prendront ces 4 mai au piège
que je fous qu'on sait que toucherait le
d5
non mais c'est gagnant mais pour jouer
quelques coups de plus dont ça fait 2-1
ou gels intervient pour la manne on est
d'accord que le temps change à chaque
fois un cycle c'est pas bête
l'idée ce jeu des 4 b et c 3
le score logique là ce serait égalité
mathieu du coin on est d'accord les deux
joueuses ont dominé une partie en à une
un peu serré qui a tourné en faveur de
kosteniuk s'était pas mis un frein ces
rares d'entre eux tu fais quoi apsys
mais il me semblait que c'était des
quatre il faut des trois qui est le
clouage près d'une sur des casques des 5
c'est un coup ici qu'est c3 je veux
jouer un peu les françaises échange je
t'aime bien fou aux absents et c'est le
même temps j'ai quatre oui tu vas jouer
aussi les dames b3 peut-être la tsarine
position qui existent ou 90 à franges et
quatre tuées le fais car lycées trois
fouilles 7d canon
c'est un petit plus ça pour les blancs
petit avantage de salut cela dérange pas
trop trop après la jouer avec 6,6 kg 17
h is projet six tours 8
non mes parents les blancs enrichie
d'une version mais je suis pas sur le
foot de trois mois ce dessin que
maintenant le fameux journal fait ça
quand elle est blond hutte en jeu des
cinq avant tes défauts abriel ce dessein
par la case des cut oui c'est à la même
position très haut blanc et que tu fais
des 5es des quatre car il y avait cinq
étaient mieux même jusqu'à les quatre
défauts voilà la ccsa québécismes et moi
dans ce genre de pression je préfère les
noirs le même si je sais que c'est rien
tu prends de a tu mettes enfants dès 6
ans qui en 17 jeux c6 b5 et b6 dans les
finales des fois faut faire gaffe ou qui
sait si ce nom ça doit aller mais je
trouve que c'est plus agréable pour les
noirs
donc est sur b4 bien entendu il ya cinq
et on peut pas faire à trois gros danger
il devait pas se départager au chili
d'un goût d'aimer ça qu'ils ont fini
ex-aequo
oui mais y avait chez plus qu elle pas
de mari le parc halde est vrai par un
règlement de départage c c ou china qui
avait le meilleur des partages info 3
c'est bien ce que dans ces structures
souvent mais mon cas les 17 que moi à me
défendre je pense à le faire ces
systèmes qui est lui tira ie5 faut deux
cousins c'est quand je te fous dit s'il
vous prend la tête et d'un 8 2005 à mai
2006 mais cinq écueil princesse appel à
vue c'est chaud plutôt bien je plutôt
très bien je donc passé ces six servait
blidéens ne sait si c'est avoir la casse
c'est cette quand tu me fais keyyo 5
pour la donne maintenant je pense
qu'elle doit prendre effet recueilli 17
ouais mais ça je préfère le blanc
cheveux beckett
maintenant je suis dans les temps pour
former 4 à 3 c'est un peu perdus pas
peut-être à 5 menaces qui avaient les
bouches
il sera 3 4 si tu perds pas le pion
c'est bien jouer et après maintenant il
le cas via quatre pour défendre plus
obligés de kayak à défaut cazaux 4
toujours parlez vous voyez les avantages
d'un communaux un goût si c'est
magnifique quand un cavalier qui part
sur l'ale regarder s'il autres cavaliers
qui était centrale peut rebondir au
centre
[Musique]
et sur a3 qui valait à 6 l'idée c'est
qu'il ya pas b4y avait pu en prend plus
en compte un autre que soi quatre
archers qui veut faire cavalier à 6 ça
c'est bizarre ce que j'allais joe dante
7 et 17 bien joué très bien je regarde
le développement de wave six taureaux 8
eb huit tours 4 après peut-être dans les
noirs géants sont mieux la panne
contenant j'avais bien confortable pour
but j'adore ta les tours b 4 6 1 qui
peuvent frauder mais for intérieur
ouais voilà une petite entaille noir
peut-être même tombé cinq jours peu de
parties ont des quatre personnes israël
ferait toro 800 tu sais pas quoi je veux
ce côté joue question c'est en fait la
tournée partout ailleurs donc la mf5
peut être intéressant non autre question
je ne sais pas je n'y aurais jamais
jouer ce coup mais tu vois je j'essaie
de poser des questions des 400 hommes
bien et tours 8 maintenant après le
possible c'est de jouer cavalier ou cinq
essais de converger sur le roi mais fait
toujours 8 non j'aurai fait tout 8 mai
géré par là elle a réfléchi peut-être à
ça parce que tu as cavaliers ou cinq
dames 2 par exemple dans l'idée que ton
plein de 4 et une grave la colonne comme
ça du fric a eu 5
non je vais faire payer 5 kg 4 n'ont
qu'à la phase iii non je serais plutôt
cavalli a fui de cavale ie6 maintenant -
chapeau taf quatre chapeaux de ces cinq
sinon dame se cette enquête futile me
lui même tour aux choeurs d'hommes c'est
cette semaine qu'a réussi c'est un de
mes plans préférez donc à bloquer les
paiements façon trop ici on veut et où
ces cas où on s'est pas mal du couloir
je n'aurais pas perdu un temps par h6 à
ce moment-là partie mathieu
non je trouve qu'il ya trop de combat
partout pour pour perdre un temps comme
ça après ça gâche pas tout le monde
quand mot d'ailleurs peut-être que c'est
un langage pas davantage mais
un black commet à des -60 kg on en est
ce que j'avais demandé je démonte pas je
comprends pas où elles vont venir double
stratégie
qu'est ce qu'une cache ci soit 4 d'alger
4e tour au 4 x 4 dames ces trois mêmes
fief si st juste d'améliorer ma position
et peut-être même si ce dernier doit
même fou des 4 après nos choix je
connais sont trop impliqué ça je
l'aurais jamais fait sa part d'être
super précis n'en faut h quatre salles
avait quand même très fort en sa
présence et celle ci sna fu grand dam
brand adams et 7,1 ses 512 mesdames
c'est cette jeunesse sera quoi non mais
peut-être qu'en fait tu prends duquel il
a tu vas pas un pion en france
pourquoi et qui avait pensé 5 oui total
veut [ __ ] un f6 d'un bref six dames b8
échec après non ainsi et alors non ça
fait rien mais je pense que c'est ce
qu'elle veut croire cette tour 8 mais ya
rien d 4 c'est papa qu'on du tout hein
si la cie sa marque sont prises et huit
taureaux un ouais tu peux bouger le
talent acta des cases 1 pour la nature
bouger tu prends ces cinq mois mais les
noirs la nomine ça va ça se passe ça se
passe plutôt bien mathieu pour voir un
peu le mans je dirais que là non
et c est là qu une issue ne tourne plus
tout à l'heure ce serait bien que là
qu'il assigne à dos tu réfléchis là
c'est cadeau mathieu des français 5 qui
avait prend tout reprend temps prend 8
dame prend 8 turbines tour en dessins
callamand 17 tu construis ton pions dans
le d5 a été super bien
[Musique]
ou prises dans le dessin peut-être plus
tôt attend il ya 17 ans
elle veut nous en à quai avec des dames
ce set je soutiens mes tours au deuxième
tour deux fois ça peut converger
rapidement quand tu rentres sur la
première image full 5 voudrait bien
jouer c'est bien je donne 3 5 2 et
comment se défendre à ces jeux peuvent
tourner jet tours et a6 aussi mais tour
à 6 avec l'idée de ramener le roi après
mais bon un peu lent je préfère des 3b
ton idée ça va égaliser 2005 se gagne g3
mc 2 mc252 d'ailleurs flashcode cricket
t'aimer terme arrive des fois nous prend
de contre-pied d'un point de le faire
normalement c'est un poids de 1 non
mesdames prendre même si dans le suivi
des médecins c'est ça ouais c'est pas
idiot non plus mais si tu fais pas de
9,5 en fait le truc c'est que ces trois
dates france et trois là peut-être raté
car elle a raté un gagnant mais c'est
beaucoup moins que rien il tord 1,8
dollar était lui bah disons que dame f5
gagner juste la partie
ouais c'est foudjem attaqué deux tombés
un peu vraiment perdu 5 trop bc3 togbui
3,7 est tombé huit elle veut faire ses
trois maris j'espère temps à 8 que vous
prendre des deux il va y avoir deux
hommes en live tous poussant des trois
tours b 8
ce 3 c'est trois tours prend dame
prendre un bain 8 des deux des deux
nattes obligés de faire des trous ouais
non tu dois faire des trois 3,8 dame 3,8
des rafales et noir ou alors au cul
ouais fallait pas reprendre à lancer
perdu mathieu fallait faire des deux
directs c'est terrible mathieu banques
et c'est maintenant j'ai pas vu ou comme
le fait d'arracher huit dames g8
ouais et à près d'1 h à 3 h un g4 bois
ce matin j'ai quinze fougeux train de
dames de dames mairie en 2005
franchissement annoncé damage c'est 3,5
dame fc3a chez garda machette trois
chocs dame prend un schisme puis on
prend des quatre matches ainsi amat yens
d'amendé
ah bon un des mes recettes mais je veux
cinq s'esquisser la partie des hordes à
9,7 et à l'abandonner en fait et j'ai
trois matches je trouve mesdames
princesse puisque j'ai dit ça marchait
pas de doute bon ça c'est terrible plus
deux avec complètement gagnant elle n'a
jamais attaqué j'aime évoluer demain ce
matin j'ai reçu que des fois elle joue
un peu du mauvais côté de l'échiquier
non bah oui oui elle lui a donné un coup
au passé après ça arrive ça avait l'air
de marcher quand même mais un phénomène
à la mode c'est intéressant de savoir ce
qu'elle a prévenu c'est bien qu'elle
change mais en tout cas c'est bien elle
change au moment où elle avait dominé la
dernière 5 c'est hyper bizien fait chine
moi je trouve déjà avant 10 heures le
fait qu'elle ait pas commencer par le
système de londres déjà de base je me
répète mais ça c'est ça qui l'a mené en
finale de la compétition c'est bizarre
de par rejouer l'ouverture avec laquelle
tu attends dominé et là y'a un truc très
foncé à son nom deux coups ou 6e couche
je fous des trains ça évitera les
cavaliers 4-0 c5
si tu fais à 3 il n'y a pas la cause de
corte
ouais et unir la caf 3 ou à la rigueur
garde le plan ou même fait cette fois
parce que du coup
et ces prix qui avaient le cap tout de
suite bon alors on joue cette position
assez insipide mais elle doit c'est bien
ces cas là parfois et se fait dominer
avec les blancs elle rejouerait dominé
les échanges
oui une logique qui est pas implacable
normalement tu retournes là vous admirez
bon écoute il ya que deux points d'écart
pour le moment après j'aime bien je
pense les blancs jeu 84 c'est très bien
pour jeu pour lui qu'un ca mais voilà
suis un peu déçu la nar j'avoue que ça
m'a mis un petit coup - terreïs ou bien
c'est bizarre et 10,8 elle a joué cinq
sets 5-7 et je dois je trouve qu'il joue
mal je suis désolé mais je trouve à
passer sur trois après peut-être qu'elle
va gagner des 5 et je vais fermer ma
benz à ces mesures la f4 là je crois et
af447 km 5 6 4
j'ai calculé coûté pas moins bien mais
du coup t'es pas mieux et est cette
fois-ci vous ces huit pas convoqué je
pense les blancs d'homme je commence à
m'en prit zeddam j'écarte kf set je peux
prendre 5
je peux prendre 4 ou prix d'un objet cas
tu fais quoi la crise a mis les quatre
noms qui va sur un ben ouais je vais
faire un ban
j'ai banni moi même comme j'étais pas
sûr qu'il y ait des motos des quatre
pour ses 7 b g iii et sur fg agf 4,5
c'est l'idée peut-être que tu peux
laisser le coup voilà fait quoi dans la
partie à fait compréhensible pour penser
dame g4 justement je joue comme on aime
en joue quand même beaucoup de bon goût
mais c'est parce mais de grosses
imprécisions qui gâche parce que niveau
fond de jeu des gains
et tous - voilà qu'il fait as-tu fait
d'amener cinq mandats merci skf si nos
stratégiquement je préfère les noirs et
les blancs dogs de dépêcher sur quelque
chose mais aurait du coup le truc c'est
que tu as beaucoup de bons coups et puis
parfois ouais t'as un plan vraiment
complètement à l'envers quoi ils ouais
je la connais pas mal parce que tel
qu'on n'en ait mal ce france ukraine
elle nous a fait du mal des fois elle a
gagné des fois facile contre nous
les choses étaient plus compliquées nous
mais ouais c'est une chose très
particulier en fait tu as dû des fois
qu'il peut gagner hyper facile et mais
qui peut aussi perdre contre n'importe
qui elle est un peu dans son camp quand
ça sera calé un peu dans son coin
bref quatre mois et elle a raison il
faut échanger que je lève 3 kgs ces
quatre jeux sur le plan des six mettent
en rang 3 et va pousser les pions et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être plus facile
agents en pratique avec les blancs mais
objectivement si les noms arrivent à
faire un blocus ils peuvent être mieux
juste ses mains pas égales c'est bien
sûr un truc 14,7 g5 est un cavalier de
saint sava libre et l'allemand
ça va être intéressant mais je remarque
que ça fait déjà la troisième ou la
quatrième finale égal qu'elle jouait
depuis le début ouais mais bon c'est
quand même a perdu 2 ce que j'allais
dire si si si tu as encore une finale
avec chance équilibré qui tourne en
faveur de kosteniuk ça commence à être
lourd
non mais c'est pas que ça c'est qu'en
fait les deux fois les dominent les
finales mais perd quand même une belle
affaire cabello 3 qui avait lieu cinq
cavaliers
5 parce que la g6 et kg 2 peut-être les
f4 je suis même pas sûr paraît logique
guerrière 2 sera plus comme mtn près il
ya une autre idée stratégique ipv4
équidés ces quatre matins cahier un des
quatre caves et les l5
c'est là une première mentionné mais je
sais pas ce que ça donne et que c'est ça
ça peut être jouable
mouais mais gris blanc 100 content qu'un
homme c'est une question d'être quatre
taureaux un iphone
mais là même si je pense ça doit aller
sur ps3 mais là ça avec le fait que le
carré puisse être délogé ces pénibles
kf5 tour 17 d'accord et 3g d'ouvragé 3
pour essayer d'en fermer la tour taoua
jeu 2 g63 de train ouais ouais donc la
b4 mange pas des quatre c4
oui toi elle suit pas le temps de jeu
qu'à des way et on y va tout droit
je ne crois pas à 4 way
ainsi free store un énorme trou de jeu
et que j'ai quatre peut-être clio 4
serait peut-être qu'il faut jouer 3
matchs 3 doit faire acheter un carré
fait qu'il y ait des 4 donc elle veut
cavalli aussi cela clairement il va voir
g4 système devait jouer fb je le vois
j'ai 3 1 pour éviter tous les jets 4 et
après seulement partir à rennes est
d'ailleurs avant bekale probable du coup
je suis d'accord avec toi de plus que
l'afrique est un des quatre 4 3g trois
tours df cette bavure à trouver parce
que un caisson b5 préserve trois prises
prise prise quand tu prends des sissi
ac3 et qu'il arrête pas imaginable il
faut prendre de ces procédures engagées
si bruxelles dont la télévision de la
tow si tu prends de gea qui prend des
six bêtes campo à john deere tour ouais
mais bon j'ai sa 307 finale l'a battue
elle est intéressante enquête est ce qu
ont qualifié 3 à 4
mais du coup c'est peut-être également
n'importe quoi akash compromis
intéressant et sur qui est des trois
levées quoi qui reprend way qu'elle
prend b4 c'est un échange voilà
attends matériellement c'est égalité il
ya deux options passé avec ses 300 sont
fragiles
le carélien e5 fait plaisir quand même
puisqu'il tient tout je pense et justine
nul je vois pas comment l'un ou l'autre
une progresse je veux mettre le rang 3
et j'ai envie de te dire tu vas mettre
leurs envies 3 d'ailleurs notre image 3
et un moment qu'il a et b1 qui a aidé 2
il y aura ces trois c'est ça m'a
expliqué à france 3 qui apprend quel
point la f3c dehors est très étonnant
mais j'ai un contrat urbain lequel f de
l'euro et des cats a toujours à rien car
ayant d un roi des quatre cavaliers f2c
switcher et alors et ça fait rien c'est
terrible c'est marrant comme position
ouest intuitivement on encore penser que
les blancs sont mieux mais y'a rien et
tu peux perdre ça il si tu cherches pour
les emmerdes derrière tu peux rien faire
b 6e tu perdrais le pion et sari pas
juste une partie intéressante adultes au
combat là vraiment bien sûr la livre est
légal finalement au rsa soit à la switch
donc ça c'est ce qu'a fait c'était quoi
l'autorité ou iphone 4 que ça pourra
éviter le bas pour éviter à petrov par
souci 5 6 1 en deux coups un peu rhin
mais qu'ils permettent en fait l'idée
c'est que des fois tu peux jouer 10 et 6
à la retarder
ça peut transposer aussi jeté hier 3
aussi ici avec l'idée des six qui a
quatre manches affaire de fous rami qui
avait joué comme ça il faut savoir
d'italiennes avec un temps de moi pour
aller noir à l'envers du coup si
l'italienne oui oui mais t'as pas mis de
carélie ans et 6
donc celle ci serait donc maintenant tu
vas devoir jeu avec des 6 ou alors que
je t'aurais 8 des 5 mais qui me paraît
pas être dans un très bon tempo
donc là il ya plusieurs plans pour les
blancs et h3 qu'avait eu deux souvent le
meilleur plan sagem pas parce que
normalement tu fais ce plan est gay ans
et 6 mai à cavaler poland 17 ce que
j'allais dire c'est que ce clouage pour
qu'il soit menaçant faut qu'ils aient
des cahiers des saints qui puisse
arriver il faut savoir qu'elle fait tout
le temps il faut 2,5 fois jusqu'à mais
pour ça que c'est bon on va est ce
qu'avec les blancs du pc jouer pour
grand roque j'aurais profité du plan h67
règles comptables peugeot toro 8 à 5 y
avait des fuites
tadic ou à faire en fait les blancs non
plus plantons m le seul plan ici c'est
daniel camus de ranger 3 ans maman mais
maintient que ce soit y aura g5 ce
terrible à nos prisons
j'ai des images insoutenables yao plan
est bon c'est dur à jouer mais bon ok
fuite
[Musique]
est ce que fout aussi c'est un coup tu
vas raymond gitane j'aime bien le garder
mais oui oui c'est pas un mauvais coup
doivent être des fois j'ai envie de dire
pourquoi en fait c'est un peu mon
ambition à laquelle tu fais tu fais pas
tu es nul non tu es pas nul mais tu
réduis la pression tu réduis le matériel
ok donc la veut dire qu'elle peut un
jour j'aurai kafka tard je ne comprends
pas je fais j'ai cinq noms 6-2 6-4
après donc maintenant les noirs ces deux
jeux pour le gain faut qu'ils jouent
pour dessein comment tu peux parce que
web pris mon dessin qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que prescrit s'il peut
y avoir un cahier une en b 5 alors pas
tout de suite en mai dans la rue c'est
vraiment un coup sa medi dc3 le fond
puces des cats pas facile pas facile de
de progresser avec les noir sans rien
donner
maintenant je sais où j'ai fait bouger
que la fête dès 5h 3 non il faut aussi
se maintenant non mais un petit avantage
d'un c'est sûr ouais je pense qu'elle va
organiser une idole dante seul je vous
prends h3c le propos avec l'idée à sur
fou prend pions prend dame prend 3 juin
il y aura dame pranger trois échecs
parce que le le pur et cloud est en tout
cas c'est plutôt rassurant quand même un
pur ou chez nina les les deux dernières
parties matures ouais elle a des halles
a des bonnes positions koala les
positions qui joue sur avec les blancs
et les noirs là elle est peut-être même
un peu mieux
mehdi ses mains c'est quand même à elle
a dominé le début de match mais non elle
est continue qu'elle domine au tout
début
q s'est fait dominer mais sur la période
de domination douche et nina keil à
marquer les points causé nuke un mois
généralement ici je serais tenté de
prendre deux pièces si je peux et b5
dame 17 c'est rohff ou 3 3 ça s'allume
et ça marche pas et des quatre ça je
trouve pas ça
ce texte est une qu'elle empêche les
fourrages trois fous des cats un coût
non tu peux tu être ma vers kébé 5ème un
jeu pourrait prendre au mieux au point
ça a l'air de très bien que je tombe
bien je tombe bien c'est qu'on puisse
que francs 6 3 par le monde menace
d'actes peut-être joué d'amd cette tour
à tour des mythes autour celui du copain
pour ses 8
voilà j'aime bien lors des 8èmes pas
pourquoi je pense qu'elle fait c'est
pour défendre un peu inquiète
qui est fou des quatre maintenant mon
idée c'est pas vraiment un truc qu'un
chien fou p 4
l'idée c'est de peu moi je protégeais
aux cinq ans malade du coup ça va
un échange et je préfère les blancs 20.5
prise prise y'a pas un des quatre qui
peut s'intercaler ça j'ai pas tout prend
1,6 kg on prend cu
je prends la f6 aussi français que je
prenais je pensais qu'il prend dans le
sens qu'une fois qu'un bon je fous anton
44.6 je me prends ces trois sages
calculé en suite pardon je suis perdu
dans la variante on prend 2,5 et là je
voulais qu'on compte les pièces un pion
de plus pour les blancs pour le volant
brad en retourne au direct elle a fait
tout retour s'est vite tour 2 pouces et
3 b c 3 tours ces trois fous au 5 mai
selanne est dense et bien c'est la même
pose à quintin deux mois après oui ça
change des passagers n'est pas énorme où
j'ai quatre pions prend que 5 qui se
gagne pain bio faux calculs aussi fou
prend f6 intermédiaires non il ya fouet
f3 fout d'eux restera food et 8 fous de
moi mais ça marche mais revoir donc qu'
on prend et qui prend 1,5
dans les bouches kelly frange des quatre
saisons en enfer mais c'est sain l'ordi
d'ituri huit dames 8 f3 et 1,30 euro la
pièce car a lieu cinq corps oui mais ça
c'est genre de truc tu peux te prendre
talent à fait fou g4g tour prend 1,5
elle peut se le prendre
ça marche toujours ce saint bah c'est là
une position tant qu'à y prend d'un f4
qui avait plongé ktef trois semaines
pierre trudeau alors mine podcast oui
latapie latapie la dame en 8 mai la
paperie à la fête tout revin c'est hyper
compliqué
or j'ai 5
une peintre joue ton de blizzard ouais
je vais bientôt ranger cinq ans même
après oui je veux donner la colonne
bondam 17 faut pas réfléchir
tu défends tout et vion et attaque
t'attrape g4 force à tour c'est cette
fois j'ai l'impression que c'est comme
si elle avait eu un avantage qu'elle
s'est mise là à jouer pour réaliser à
temps c'est la première fois où j'ai
vraiment mis autant oui elle a accéléré
vous peut-être que son manque de
précision vient d'annuler 7 mai et
peut-être aurait-elle gagne pas au monde
puisqu'il ya des cinq ans de prison et
on qu'efficace eastman ont maintenant du
mal la version d'un jeu j'ai trois
logiques réserve a les oreilles coupées
noms des quatre avait joué ce 3éme et
ouais ouais ça me surprend aussi étroite
a fait bien peu ton est là avec un des
quatre si tu pouvais mais laquelle est
un des quatre îles des soins monstrueux
dans les finales ce qu'ils veulent en
bessin quand f5 honda le 17 il faut voir
langage auquel le jour que c'est chose
faite
surtout reprend 1,7 à le surprendre du
cavalière par ferme elysées sinon ouais
ou des systèmes paris dsy pa et e4 b
chine inde était aussi b5 crainte le
passé à temps et si ce feuilleton prend
le dos d'un produit étranger 4 c'est pas
juste un pion puisque fou prend des 5 g
dames prendrait 5 sur échec
je dois le faire un dolphin bon
maintenant ses pions de plus mais ça
reste compliqué à gagner
bon ben là c'est aux blancs de montrer
quelque chose oui revient sont bons
crise qui est en quête pendu pion de la
dame
je pense qu'elle va prendre du plomb
mais
[Musique]
50 secondes pour push et nina quand l
égalité après franck avait eu 4 je pense
ça lui fait du bien de gagner une partie
à mathieu oui voila j'ai moins qui suit
pour voir qui suit pas pour gagner on
est jugée poncet connu délégué ni la
chine elle mérite de gagner ça l'a
clairement parce qu'elle a dominée à la
pendule et is watching et le 4gates va
pouvoir venir en c5 ou 5 c'est bien tard
à 4 en l'air
u17 tu prends la fin tu fait qu'elle une
immense et 3 es tu vas prend sa vraie et
eut contrôlé case blanche tu files mais
va le loupé elle l'a fait cai c5 d'amd
5,25 foulée 5 qui avait là qu'à trouver
cette crise et 3 c'est la partie mathieu
26 well as pas louper et maintenant à
43,2 à l'égal de jouer à chaque non non
non donc y'a même pas où des cinq ans
puis c'est terrible bonbons bien qu'on
nous voue qui ait du suspense qu'elle
aurait pu faire fois ci sous ces quatre
essayant que joue encore le pion c'est
même si ça perdait ça fait 4 3 première
victoire pour ou chez nina mathieu qui
revient vraiment complètement dans la
rencontre alors b6 qui est une ligne
qu'elle a déjà joué un qui est juste pas
très bonne mais il faut connaît on
démonte et joue beaucoup ça en ce moment
rapide c'est pas bête sipa piégeurs mais
f3 pas te mentir c'est un bon coup près
par quatre sa part à 4 n'ont qu'à le bon
coup s'écaille 6,6 donc le fait qu'elle
réfléchisse sur le meilleur coup ça fait
peur carcasse est possible qu'elles
connaissent vraiment pas arcis sur la c4
1 alex dunn commencé sur un mât non mais
là ya quatre ou cinq ça ça va poindre sa
transposons cavalli assister ici sauf
que tu as quand tu fais avec quatre
super un thème pour non666 et humer le
français 5e terrible on m'avait dit tu
peux montrer aux six si bien fort vas y
tu joues j'ai quasiment à escales ce
super québec est bon même kg se situer
je sais qui je suis d'ailleurs de c3 et
c3 picasso sur celle en fait étape à y
descendre la bonne ligne on peut le
montrer sur kst 6 ce qui s est 3e 5 des
5 et qui avaient des bouchauds quatre
cailloux cette photo mlg du jeu par
moussa est ici j'ai catete jeu pratiqué
par une mais quatre
c'est le coup non au café des six
caisses et 3 kg s'il faut 3 5 gammes des
deux est là c'est une mauvaise indienne
parce que pour ce soit ok pour une offre
pays tant que je ashes qui achètent
fauché cinq noms mais si ça leur fait si
c'est pas le problème mais 20,6 faut que
tu arrives à l'échangé de classement et
là je vais jamais de laisser alors je
peux jouer le g3 g4 oiseaux sauvages
soit 3 way c'est une bonne série et
après je suis 400 et les chiens h 4 601
fille h4 c'est fort
hk tu as changé 3 de plat tout en
souplesse
je te feront toutes les cases je
t'échange nous faut deux cases blanches
les costumes je trouve qu'elle est quand
même un peu quand compte conejo avait
quand même beaucoup dominé dans le jeu
stratégique 1 mais c'est une brute de
calcul à la joueuse que lundi c'est une
brouille de calcul et les hyper
concentrée elle est hyper affûté et
herrade peu de choses en fait quand tu
lui donnes un truc dont 10,6 le plan ça
va être de même de jouer à 4 t'empêche
tout contre eux je tue mike haviland
détroit et fait foi croix rouge aidés
après peut-être tu travailles verser 6
kgs c1 c'est bien joli scoop b57 emprise
maintenant mais vous c'est une année
vraiment bien au niveau des plans je
trouve ça quand même souvent des bons
plans à l'âge de 2-3 fois l'envers mais
fondamentalement elle ce tabou quand
même très bien mathieu donc son idée ça
doit être super 5 jo c'est cinq
thématiques
qui souvent très très correct c'est
parfait c'est parfait tiens ce qu'elle
est née du coup la poste laquelle à la
poussée après 1h30 de jeu ouais alors
après ça dépend à quel point les parties
ont recommencé ou pas c'est après mais
ça après une heure et demie vrai tour
c'est un elle va faire b 4 c 5 j'imagine
[Musique]
après faut mieux tu vas le prince f4 et
s'adonnant la cage des catins simple et
jouer pour g4 faut être sûr que ça
marche général ça ne marche pas trop si
elle pas de mauvais coups
kefu h3 abba va prendre je donne ces 8l
5-1 et l3 peut être faible c'est un
cavalier dans ces cas là est mis en d2
c'est pour ça peut-être que fou j'ai
deux peut être un coup ouais projet deux
gardes un peu l'attention et fraude ou à
double sens pas prêt ce qui inquiète un
peu pour elle c'est que là je fais
prises et kf2 sans infléchir kosteniuk
elle peut être pénible dans ce genre de
position ouais ce cas la nac bien elle
calcule bien et elle peut te mets gunino
c'est c'est la version encore plus
extrême de sa salle d'arts stratégie on
se fout complet la règle nina c'est
c'est un problème c'est que pour
l'initiative oui à quel point on peut
pas jouer un autre type d'échec donc
carrément maintenant les blancs peuvent
jeu juste petit rôle que par faut juste
faire gaffe à ce pion f3 qui peut être
faible mais si on peut mettre un fou un
cadre faut des trois échanges et
reprendre une dame m 1,44
on va commencer à dominer à rocroi g de
lenovo romain dardaine sur 17 points ou
son rêve sept gendarmes et joie bien
dame s'est vidée set elle essaie de
doubler sourire mes objectifs après rock
elle peut aussi lui envoyer un quai
prince cat et ça peut la faire chier
bref c'est ce qu'a laissé pascal à ce
qu'elle veut jouer d'ailleurs en fait si
hier foot et 3g 6 ans donc je comprend
pas les coûts foot est roi je pense
ajoute m ponant ce que tu veux remettre
ton faut en aucun cas tu défends tout
uche a pas tout dit sur france 5 vous
aux quatre dames 8 mais là y'a pas le
feu dame c2 qui gagne ça n'a pas gagné 6
à tour m6 qu'elle est nulle et tout
réussi j'ai pas fou g5
je ne vais pas lui qui avait promis on
prend ta pâte cas sur la veille sur la
6ème d'hommes ce2 de jouer
vous savez une pièce reste partie là de
kosteniuk un mail ed si c'était vraiment
étrange mathieu baisse et nettement
baissé ça me rend fou quand ça arrive à
mes élèves je suis content quand c'est
arrivé aux autres parce ce qu'aime la
ligne principale du fichier pour moi oui
ah bah oui si tu joues plus c'est une
petite ligne sur une petite ligne est
bon allez il ya quand même pas mal de
troupes loyales ans mais ça c'est c'est
le plus logique on allait enfin je veux
non ce pack logique mais c était censé
savoir que c'est le plus chiant en fous
j'ai 5 c c'est game guide où elle a fait
feu 4 c'est terrible ah non mais parfois
il est quand même des coups j'ai du mal
à comprendre
non mais c'est un super que stratégique
mais juste à droite te bouger le cul à
calculer de peau elle faire l'offre l'a
vu elle fait un peu du mazeau clowns ont
fait un peu comme celle où j'ai quatre
ça gagne pas je pense ça fait mal c'est
un peu la même chose que quand elle a
raté deux dames f5 dames c'est de tout à
l'heure un engrais toi elle à l'apa le
radar le radar qui s'allument un truc
dingue ou nina tu mettre toutes les
positions là et un radar en est les
avoirs foot et cinq en une demi-seconde
savoir comment ça mathieu
j'ai l'impression que c'est le truc le
plus facile à travailler à titre
personnel j'aurais juste eu spam les
exos tactique et ses marchés elles ont
fait des millions
[Musique]
ouais c'est une même question c'est
comment te forcer à voir ça passe quand
même fou g5 c'était le début sans ordi
un masque ou la rue c'était juste ça me
paraissait juste évident quoi la torah
le protège et tu la taxe et ou quoi mais
maazou genou il est capable de rater
c'est dur mais pourquoi calculé le fut
mieux moi ça je rate pas vains alors un
tueur at patois normalement tu rates pas
pour maintenant peut-être qu'elle joue à
trois b 4 c 5 non le double jeu qui
avait m6 a ressassé pourquoi je
regardais sont fous je pense et m6 et le
lfb un oui je suis d'accord avec toi
mais fucam des trucs vraiment
intéressant mais parsemée de coups merde
à b4 enfin c'est qu'elle devait faire à
5 attendu juste un truc intéressant
excuse moi je reviens et nous dit on
nous dit qu sur elle avait peur juste
par curiosité
keiper de tourcoing f3 metref 3 gagne
deux pièces du ghana non là c'est pas
une question de perth une question de
pas vu donc alors placé son cavalier
aucun elle la déchire stratégiquement
mais enfin c'est le pendule g4 je n'en
parle pas zhu pets quatre de l'autre
côté c'est bien aussi
alger le 4 juin par le bas j'ai quatre
ans plus tard à noyal
enfin j'ai l'impression que même si tu
prends prend prend prend prend ses
compétences pour être souvent moi je
fonçais g5 mais tous rêvent peut-être ça
a l'air d'être très bien non je te
donnerai tout ce que tu peux m'attaquer
mais un geste en vue juste faire d'alger
car elle gêne et adam g 4 nuls beaucoup
bien jaune rouge pour tous alors la fée
food et 3 à 5 c 5
ça c'est de bien jouer encore mais pas
le truc en est c'est que stratégiquement
c'est bien mais mais d'un point de vue
pratique tu peux juste gagner la partie
d'où son idée c'est pas forcément de
reprendre ça peut être le jeu pour
à la va prendre on est rentrés avant
défense et 7 way ans et 6,6 garde la
plus de 23 secondes un groupe et on va
la perdre cela veut dire il ya qu un des
cinq britanniques
il faut qu'elle fasse quoi prise d'armes
des deux peut-être pour défendre ce
trade ou c4 métaux non- normalement tu
de tes sensations je sais vous tombez 6
et tu repars non si tu te fais chasse et
kershaw a assez bien joué c'est encore
d'un point de vue pratique les 5 1 puis
elle a peu vu ça l'avait pas vue elle
avait raté en août et j'ai cup avec 4 6
4 fu b5 pas mal aussi
non du coup tu échanges tout est calme
comme vous voyez bon c'était mal choisi
on va jouer mathieu mais bon j'essaye de
non objectivement allait peut-être même
pas encore moins bien ce roi de 3,4 la
lgv égard la casse pour le calme à ce
qui est aussi cela mathieu mais hull de
costil bon ouais j'aurais mangé 3 ile de
france est assez bizarre non
est ce que je crois c'est dommage oui il
est le dj 3,2 fois assez dommage ça ne
prend pas ce qui est dit ici c'est
manquer bécistes être c'est chiant tu
t'attaques la tour quai 17 5 points ce
week-end mais tu veux tu être monté le
roi je passais showmatch avec peu de
temps ouais mais maintenant mais
peut-être fou des trois fous des bretons
mauricie
maintenant il ya pions passé mutuelle et
à l'époque et 3 qui défend tous elle est
tombée mais away c'était sur le scénario
était écrit d'avancé
mathieu mais c'est ben en fait elle
manque de jeu pratique c'est elle c'est
la dominent tellement vraiment beaucoup
plus forts stratégiquement elle a dominé
vraiment de la tête et des épaules un
mois au début quand
au début c'était plutôt l'inversé mais
survient de faire des petits les noirs
dominent
je dirais durée sur huit partis on a
peut-être 2 2 pour kosteniuk quatre
coureurs ou chez nina et de égal mais le
score il est beau lieu d'être de +2
parce que tu conclus tête et positions
gagnantes il est il à linverse quoi mais
du coup le dollar miné sérieux alors je
sa première minute je pense que manon
pour alexandra la stratégie de match
c'est de cette sphère serrure jusqu'au
bullet mais mon but je pense que bullet
hell est vraiment au dessus non je pense
aussi donc du coup tu as plus de
mentorat peine une heure de trois plus
un thé cei de faire la serrure et au
pire c4 c4 ces appareils tous les sept
essais 4 ces appareils monfils et 7
alors pas prise prises et j'aurai
peut-être tour 8 j'en sais rien moi je
peux pas manger de b2f 5 kg 5
non c'est gai g5 je veux et un d'amd 6 à
la fée tours 8
mais ils ont dû s est quelque chose
ressemblant ray ya comme une game en
fait ça marche pas comme ça sinon qu'aux
débutants
oui et je t'annonce que le match va
durer puisque la partie là vient de
commencer quand il restait plus qu'une
minute au chrono et donc et donc c'est
une partie qui va durer a qui va durer
longtemps
pour la cnaf en fait sur le total des
captures première kosteniuk 2e ex-aequo
ou chi minh et moulinets ou finale
devant des portages quatrième katia 5e
ça ça date
c'est un slot elle s'appelle sarah gadon
contre nous parce al assad que les
marchés restent floues il est 6ème ou
iphone là on est d'accord que sarah
salle at-il son prénom voudront fut son
prénom complet et doivent utiliser gt
coupé
sixième du classement après sait où ils
femme puis koné roux prochaine bulle
je n'ai pas appris par coeur enfin
peut-être cas ici quatre maintenant à
quelqu'un qui est un gain
mais ces épisodes thaler de parent
l'avoir tenté ça faisait sept suspects
soir qu'elle avait lu un voile baisse de
mais encore une place stratégique man tu
fais 5 fait j'ai l'impression qu'il
bouge mieux les pièces mais qu'elle est
beaucoup moins forte tactiquement mais
tactiquement lé genre beaucoup moins
forte
parce que kosteniuk tu vois pour l'avoir
vu une nouvelle fois moscou blitz et
contre contre les meilleurs les
meilleurs blitzer chez les hommes elle l
arnaque vraiment en même en amical des
mecs super fort mais elle a déjà battu
plein de 27 briolin katia katia s'est un
peu entre les deux mais cela ne la
trouvais pas si fort dans les pas
mauvaise mais elle
je suis pas sûr que ce soit beaucoup au
dessus que co signent ou sur internet
après il ya aussi peut-être le fait pour
katia que comme ella ella les gamins la
maison elle a beaucoup de gamins la
maison c'est peut-être plus difficile de
couper quand tu joues tu chez toi le ton
une enseigne août et continue et une
fille mais moi oui mais une c'est par
une c'est une quoi à ses dépens d'agen
yani yanev adeline ça peut suffire à toi
tu parle en connaissance de cause
seniors bah du coup quatre ils ont
brison 4 à la maîtresse et l'allemand
ils ont quatre à la maison 4 c'est quand
même je crois qu'ils ont trois ou quatre
dans le catch up nude maker faire mes
consignes ou que l'a été aussi
et comment elle s'appelle pendant sa
dernière sarah cap fait un tour correct
mais un spécial a été vice championne du
monde en rapide ebit ceci oui donc sur
une journée ou deux tout peut arriver
mais oui ça reste une super joueuse mais
tu sais il ya aussi ce matin c'est
différent quand même c'est pas le même
jeu comme but de ce pont niasse yassa ya
aussi le fait tu sais qu'il ya des
joueurs qui sont plus forts en tournoi
suisse qu'en match inverse ouais c'est
un facteur il ya plusieurs facteurs qui
rentrent en compte
alors à chaque fois qu en tant que papa
d'un bébé de six mois dès que ça
récupère 50 points depuis n'est-ce pas
facile mathieu un commentaire je préfère
la petrov et pour des ventés pas trop
dur si on the bright noot a de quoi en
ce moment elle travaille pour un exam
met donc c'est un peu dur c'est
l'enchaînement avec mélo si on peut
partir en vacances en août ça fera du
bien à voir sa famille tu pars avec la
petite
c'est bien je préfère la console lorsque
jusque c'est pour moi c'est plus facile
de parler de la paix trotte dans ces
frissons qui campe chiante à regarder un
faut surtout pas bouger le cahier des
doigts côté hissé car il quitte en tant
qu on se doit de donner lacazette 4 là
comme ça
ton premier avis j'effaçais ça me parait
space mountain de faire j'ai quatre
tandis que peugeot lâche 5 km franck et
f5
bien vu elle sympa ça scola l'atome
dames deux quarts aller à un endroit
j'ai le rejet de cette fraîche et sèche
de l'avoir menace car il ya quatre les
assez dur à voir
ouais bon je l' ai vu l affaire à six
médailles 9 4 ici mais tu vois si c'est
un coup que moi j'arrive juste pas à
comprendre c'est pas quoi faire mesdames
quatre chemins je pense en fait je
pensais peut-être un coup comme moi j'ai
sept au lieu de 1,6 au lieu d'un roi je
sais trop bien plus menacées achats mais
c'était l'idée de ne pas laisser les
familles quinze jours surtout reprend
1,8 soit pas sur échec
bon écoute un quelqu'un qui demande quel
est ton score kosteniuk été légèrement
devancé zain a les moyens devant ouais
je mène 23 15 c'est pas mal c'est un bel
avantage mais bon j'ai la chance d'avoir
les conseils de vlad pour l'abattre que
c'est exactement quoi faire
c'est un peu méchant mais en gros jeu
stratégique ça gagne tout seul
mais avec d'autres mots est banni
tactiquement elle a beaucoup d exaucer
les vraiment les plus affûtés que nous
y'a pas ouais il m'a dit par contre si
tu si tu la laisses rentrer dans les
tactiques soulès de l'attaqué si elle
s'y est là l'activité elle est juste
beaucoup plus forte que toi moi je
prendrai mes 5 à 500 plus manqué lui
aussi ses indélogeable puisqu'il ya plus
qu un rêve qui peut le chasser
donc maintenant si tu arrives à ouvrir
un deuxième colonne elle peut être atone
l'abbé cinq jours j'aurai thème pourquoi
pim aussi en plus des fautes que je paye
ses caps qui a éprouvé prend oui enfin
je pencherais b5 et je mettrai la tour e
en b 8
enfin georges fourré plutôt comme ça je
dirais la colonne tu la touchera jamais
donc je me barre de cette colonne là je
te dirai pas du tout fait ça 18h25 c'est
la colonne de les fermer a pas d'amour
il est là je refais ricard a lieu au
système pos et toi à nous la ddt elle
nous l'a déjà fait ça tout à l'heure de
vouloir trop égaliser en fait mais pas
comprendre le moment à vos besoins en
fait elle joue bien les positions entre
un peu moins bien et un peu mieux mais
elle n'arrive pas à transformer un peu
mieux en décisif non y'a quelqu'un qui
pose une question
pas mal dans l'hudson non il ya quand
même une différence entre les beats et
les longues particulièrement seulement
aux joueurs de beats abcès différents
pas un mauvais joueur de l'ong jeudi
mais tu as quand même beaucoup moins de
chance de bahts plein de j'aimais de gm
en parlant clairement très clairement
très clairement j'ai déjà battu des
gisements longue mais mais je fais
beaucoup de nuls - contre légèrement
longue web et avait ainsi de trestles
énormément nul c'est un truc de ouf je
gagnais pas souvent j'ai dit qu'avec
mazor s'est amusé à compter nos normes
de grand maître
et alors ça j'en ai 30
bon je mérite le titre et je voulais le
chanvre est un pote cas n'a pas vendu ne
fut pas comme ça presque
tout fait encore un nom je suis d'accord
avec elle on jouera pas le chercher
parce que sur le très long terme assure
mme hartmann juste c'est parfois non ça
pour une fois je suis d'accord avec qui
est mieux personnes mal à cazaux de
quatre bébés ça que j'aime bien c'est
tellement dommage de pas de faire la
même chose avec b 5 avec juste les
tourangeaux est à tour en v8 qui
commence à rayonner c'est qu'il aimait
un gym que chacun de vous a battu pour
avoir une langue comme un rêve pour
avoir chaque titre aux échecs
donc ça peut être maître international
granato dont nous sommes il faut avoir
un niveau minimum pour grands maîtres et
2005 et faire trois normes
qu'est ce qu'une norme une norme c'est
dans un tournoi de neuf rondes sur une
performance supérieure à 2600 donc c'est
quand même pas trop mal donc là peut
mettre un cahier un c4 et c5 est pas
vrai parce que cavalia fiscales et paie
600 cas il ya huit ans par ailleurs
n'ont servi que par f si j'attaquais g4
qui gagne un tel saut c'est pas fou et
donc pour répondre le plus fort que
gibeau dessus moi j'ai fait nul contre
car selon moi ce n'est pas un c'est bien
plus fort j'ai battu sur le papier se
dote eliane off met d'ailleurs elle est
commentée sur la chaîne pour la
retrouver
on l'a fait y'a pas si longtemps mais
non on l'a fait il ya longtemps c'était
à trois ans ah oui s'est quant à elle
fait l'arago inouïe c'est sur la rade au
sinn et j'étais en lituanie comptant
avait tourné tous vaincus et sinon j'ai
battu maxime
je rappelle à chaque fois le port de
pions se rejoue pas il peut pas bon il
faut pas jouer
ouais mais bon la fois que tu leur joie
à mon avis ça va faire mal
encore que si la prépa passe et qui je
peux faire nul mais battre maintenant
c'est quasi non comme si c'est qu'elle
veut commence à être mieux avec les
blancs non mais c'est pas ce cas là
dessus on h bassin je pense que c'est
juste la pendule qui me fait peur
al wafeer carré d as faim qu'avait lieu
3 les champions des chefs vivent de ça
c'est à dire quoi bah c'est leur métier
oui
ah bah oui mais 9e 18 pages fonctionne d
échec oui mais tu vois c'est une
question pertinente re il ya encore
s'entendre ça ce n'était pas le cas
non mais je dirais même il n'ya pas que
les très très bon là bon on n'est pas
mauvais mais on vit des échecs après
l'industrie mme du blitz moi je donne
des cours et je joue en ce moment pas
trop quand même c'est un peu égoïste
serait possible il ya des tournois là
maintenant qu'ils sont nouveaux regrets
d'un élève j'ai des élèves qui sont en
tournoi en grèce
pourquoi la custo pions pour le terrain
oui j'ai été champion de france mais
ouais mais je suis pas top mondial
est ce que tu penses que ça se gagne
pour les blancs ça si tu prends ces
quatre à l'april otfried l'ouest c'est
bien joué mais ça c'est super c'est
horrible qu'ils avaient dépensé 4 qui on
prend re trois rois g3 assez terrible
assez bien pour le match par contre si
reims troyes wah wah wah j'ai quatre
matches je n'ai pas vu ni roi g2 est
mort il ya plus de cases et l'autre
faire des six suspense dé 6,3 points f1
il ya eu cinq échecs loupé mais elle
était si seule chance joue un coup f2 au
nom au nom assez terrible les hyérois
des quatre passes et 5
olala c'est incroyable de rater ça juste
f2 c'est ce qu'a rappelé c'est que même
au côté duquel armée contente pas là
mais pas la cas mais non elle en rigole
mais c'est incroyable de parfaits f2 nom
est ce que je pourrais vivre que des
gains en fait il ya en 2018 2017 2008
j'avais un jeu jouable pas mal j'ai fait
une bonne année si j'avais vraiment
voulu j'aurais pu mais ça aura été à la
rage songeons pas mal de petits tournois
j'avais 2006 en 2006 en vain je gagnais
pas mal de peine c'est vrai mais pas de
la gagner vraiment bien honnêtement et
après j'aimais bien l'idée de faire 50 %
entraînement 50% jaune ça me donne un
équilibre et c'est aussi un luxe comme
ça je pouvais choisir mais
j'ai sonné le manger que des élèves
intéressant ça c'est intéressant pour
moi je veux que ça soit un challenge -
entraîneur tu veux pas que ce soit pour
l'argent parce qu'à partir de monde ça
sera ça sera peut-être pas que des
éléments intéressants
franchement moi c'est cool mais tu les
aimes juste l'idiot la crise tout petit
peu moins bon mais ils sont hyper
motivés donc défaut ça compense tulle et
dévie sur le volet ouais ouais je refuse
de beaucoup j'en ai pas trop au plus
haut je peux finir tu refuses beaucoup
ouais mais jusque quand j'ai mon ombre
11e on nombre global mais tu prend
combien d'élèves par semaine combien de
cours par semaine
combien d'heures on va dire pas combien
d'élèves combien d'heures de cours dans
notre test fenioux si ce n'est pas un
athlète way entre 10 15 10 et 20 c'est
pas mal ouais je pense la moyenne c'est
plutôt 10 prix mais je demande que
j'imagine que c'est un boulot qui
demande beaucoup de préparation parce
que tu es élèves doit être assez fort ou
à la variante sarah sadate le court tu
peux pas arriver les mains dans les
poches
c'est en fait c'est toujours plus facile
avec un élève quand c'est le début parce
que t'as pas besoin d'appareil mais
quand ça fait deux trois ans s'est fait
dire bien sûr oui ça c'est pour tout le
monde pareil
après c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
faut savoir aussi passer la main un
moment parce que même pour eux ça
s'essouffle c'est une tente pour une
blague un peu grivoise mamet papon ce
jour pas aujourd'hui pas aujourd'hui
mais pas après tout fait après tout ce
qu'on a fait vrai après tout ce qu'on a
fait mais aurait elle est et entendre
quand même il ya une pause du coup loupe
voyez une petite pause on fait une pause
je vais me chercher un truc à boire
jeune fille chérie honnêtement il fait
chaud ce moment là ok on se retrouve on
se retrouve en trois minutes
repas sada reparti en redif et mines cub
a tout de suite
et oui tout le monde je vous mets une
petite pub attendait après une journée
des échecs ça correspond à quoi beaucoup
de signes jour natale des échecs qui
organisait en ce jour après à quoi ça
correspond bien à part à pas grand chose
j'ai envie de dire si mais c'est passé
juste une journée internationale quoi ça
a été décidé comme ça et mais voilà mais
ça ça change rien à notre vie quoi c'est
pas un jour férié ou quoi que ce soit
allez petite pub et on se retrouve
je suis déjà de retour mais tu vas
bientôt
nir
dans quatre cas pas des gens qui me
disent qu'ils n'ont pas eu la pub
écouter tant mieux pour vous c'est
difficile pour pour anna ou chez nina
qui tourne alors je me suis peut-être
mettre le score aussi à côté de leur nom
pour qu'on puisse bien voir qui tourne
avec avec un certain retard un retard de
deux points
vraiment contre le cours du jeu et on a
l'impression avec mathieu ça va faire
que s'empirer
par la suite deux secondes du match qui
part qui revient mas dieu qu'ils
impriment quelque chose sur le papier
qui est favorite or sur le papier il n'y
avait pas vraiment de favorite je dirais
matthieu remmy kosteniuk moi ou chez
nina et bizarrement on peut donner
raison aux deux d'un côté parce que
c'est nuke mène au score ou chez nina
mène sur les positions et donc ça aurait
pu tourner dans un sens ou dans l'autre
c'est c'est vraiment difficile de de
détacher une favorite un pur pour 7 pour
cette finale
on va voir comment ça ça a évolué dans
la deuxième partie de match en trois
plus un mais il semblerait maintenant
que causé nuke et quand même pris le
dessus psychologiquement tout du moins
maintenant il ya soixante nu de 3 + 1
donc là on a eu le la première la
première partie du match et c'est
reparti avec la deuxième partie du match
donc les amis avec mathieu qui sut
mathieu qui suis-je donc des quatre
cavaliers fils qui avec 3 b6 fou fou g5
alors ça si vous rappelez bien je vais
montrer une partie marrante avec cavalli
ces trois autres jours si vous avez
suivi à la petite master class sur le
contrôle du centre rouge et 5e si c'est
là que quatre faux progressiste d'un
problème six cavaliers ces trois
peut-être jouable ou fou détroit et le
truc qui est cool pour les blancs c'est
qu'on a gagné le contrôle du centre est
bon on peut quand même prétendre à un
petit avantage grâce à soi donc petit
rock et peut-être maintenant c'est trois
qui est b d2 ou qui réalisent ces 3 ou
c4 qui a réalisé trois mètres était de
retour tu as juste raté les premiers
coups du 3 + 1 min la mi temps et on
obtient way assez bizarre pour moi je
connais avec les normes c'est mieux
quand je dessine des huit soupçons comme
ça ouais après mois la vente avec ton
possible mais qui a valu à eux deux
pions avec 4 et karelia f3 ouais mais là
elle peut pas juste à l'ap a pu dès lors
de coups et mais moi je disais que ça ça
peut être un petit peu plus agréable
pour les blancs tout de même talent tu
as le centre non il y en a qui dit une
bêtise non c'est du sud j'ai dit ça me
dit khaled pas préparer mes
parce que quand je sais ce que je vais
faire après il ya des fois je dois
travailler et sarah elle est sympa comme
élève non mais c'est une personne qui
est super cool mais juste tu vas tu es
tu vas faire rêver du monde la mâture à
la thaïlande fans
elle est hyper cool hyper sympa hyper
souriante et wes et mis lé mieux comme
ça que quand vous le regardez avec le
voile est hyper sérieuse quand elle joue
aux échecs dans la vie de tous les jours
elle est pas comme ça et souriante pong
et rigole tout le temps mondial lors des
5 tu nous vends du rêve là mathieu des 5
7 juin justifiant voilà peut-être tu as
joué avec arrêt des rafles exigé 3 et
non kg 3h 4h 5h et oui elle est élégante
à des classes bien éduqué mais après
juste elle s'en fout tu as des échecs
marc vds me suis dit son problème c'est
qu'elle n'a pas besoin d'eux échec
elle aime ça les fortes et tout mais
elle n'a pas besoin de se faire mal pour
un genre qui signent pas la sacrifier
beaucoup d'énergie aux échecs
ah oui elle elle était vraiment
déterminés à réussir que c'est mieux
qu'un seul parti ça qui lâche 2 kg 4
tours c'est du classique
c'est écrasant c'est assez classique des
françaises qui se passe mal pour les
noirs desseins que tout allait encore là
il faut joseph 115 ch peut être 5
justement de ne pas écouter les souhaits
de l'activité tours 3-1 t'as même pas
d'un point dé 4 l'affouage cette façon
bien pour kelkoo a parcouru mais à sarah
un job mais son mari un très bon job et
non mais même à gagne déjà correctement
avec les échecs mais j'ai un lapin
l'objectif ultime des sur le minimum
quand elle s'en fiche
ben c'est la seule explication jugée
parce que parce qu'on helmand par an par
rapport à yoann john haley labatut
l'autre jour il est qu une déconnexion
mais je n'allais pas ridicules contre
elle mais cela est à laval 4 en achat
direct en pleurs ouais ouais on a
commencé quand elle faisait championnat
junior dont elle avait 20 ans et demi
maintenant 20 ans
non non c'est son procès son métier mais
juste c'est les cetc un peu en
dilettante sais pas
j'aurais très tour atroce mais s'il faut
de protéger un pion qui était pas en
privé de jfk plein c'est peut-être bien
je mets f4 prise à tour f1 parce que tu
peux pas prendre un premier cas d'échec
oui c'est sûr l'échec faudra pas prendre
ma f4 comprend toile f1 est ton point f4
ça fait mal hein rires h quid de sochaux
jeudi qu'ils s'en aillent tous d'un coup
de sang efs qui traitera de et c3 et c3
et tout à l'heure ça enfermer la dame
emma avec tours c'est 8,7 on prend ces
trois sagan kalinka loches qua non y'a
pas fou bien qu'il y ait une âme en
peine 9 ans à 4 mai football hockey c3
ces dames gratuite en face et qualité et
puis la dame reste enfermé mais on peut
tu menacer nos prêts flou mais oui et
bien encaissé vrai c'est incroyable non
mais c'est complètement gagne encore
mais non mais je sais mesdames 7
c'est un peu comme tout à l'heure au
lieu de ton adversaire abandonne elle
joue encore et peut-être tu va la gagner
peut-être pas mais c'est encore tu vas
tu dois faire des efforts ici pour
pâques et b5 a eu des six comprend pas
ok ikeda mené deux sets à un moment je
l'aï trouvé plus affûtés tactiquement
pendant le ça dépendait des matchs les
matches c'est vrai la paire de
cuissardes et b5 et 5,7 à kadam ce qu'a
dit si tu prends la veille le fou fou b5
pas bêtement plus elle veut prendre les
farc et b5 et b6 non non c'est bien
mais en fait se faire inviter un point g
seul comme ça et ne pas être puni en
fait c'est ça me fait mal au coeur
elle va être puni t'inquiète pas elle va
prendre la farq et b5 et l'a5 aussi ta
tombe elle intervient f4 il jouait très
bien mes jambes sont qu'elle aime bien
jouer quand même des deux côtés de
l'échiquier
c'est peut-être un défaut dans certaines
participantes elles dominent pas assez
et après ça ça doit aussi se hyper
chiant pour compte adversaire que tu
sais pas de quel côté va taper c'est
vrai mais bon je pense que ça lui joue
des tours quand même certaines fois et
là ça doit être ma tempête reprise qui
est si sûre g3 mettant proche de 5
ben ça c'est hyper difficile de prévoir
ses coûts en fait à tour ses huit
comprend g5 ça peut pas tenir
j'ai pas vu de match 7 g 6 après juste
mais c'est bien gentil lecavalier
voilà tout juste qu'elle le vaut tu peux
prendre la chouette
ouais non mais quel point f8 calais hi3g
set je sais pas c'est pas si simple coup
de mer trois cavaliers 17
un problème de cette oreille
voilà vraiment de honnêtement je la
connais quand même pas mal au china ll
est monté dans mon estime cette semaine
enfin ce tournant ce mois partie parce
que l a montré comme de la classe dans
beaucoup de position à laquelle lots en
longues ou chez nuit là elle a une très
bonne fête quand elle a été quand elle a
gagné coupe du monde et s'est préparé
comme une dingue avec qui gagnent
d'offres il ya une grosse équipe
permettent elle a perdu et après ces
lieux mais un gros comment allait pas
mal descendu en fait elle a combien
aujourd'hui à peu près tu sais c'est
qu'ils sont vraiment bas alors 24 50
ainsi 81 24 16 il joue beaucoup mieux
que ça a un peu beaucoup mieux joksas
âgées aucun doute à 24,16 c'est
maigrichon 1
elle a eu combien ans max 25 500 trains
dans les gares des mus à les 25 plus que
25 à 24 70 25 15 25 de près donc à n'a
pas été non plus le tirage avait j'avais
été un peu plus forte quand même non
c'est pour ça que ça m'a surpris qu'elle
joue aussi bien ce tournoi mais enfin
qu'est la montre est quand même des
trucs intéressants vraiment vraiment
évidente mais après ça et que si
tactiquement elle laisse autant de
choses passés loin des terrains du coup
mais pas deux oui plus qu'un point
d'écart mais fera jour d'ailleurs il ya
plus qu'un point d'écart parce qu'ils
avaient deux points d'écart est là elle
vient de gagner donc il ya plus qu'un
point donc bon après il faut prendre 5
c'était moche s'il allait blanchir
miossec l'inde bas tarif 4,5 contre le
pauvre fillon des 5 c'est un truc à
venir et pikachu et illégal d'envoi
poussé f5
je me demandais si on pouvait pas tenté
de faire cavalier aux six gagnants tempo
et qui essaient 5 pour essayer de forcer
les changes de cavale
mal transat est peut-être mal jusqu'à 5
et 6 torje trois tourtes d1
ça m'a surpris je serai toujours fn
rouge
elle tirait son pic writing c'est en
2007 ans et déjà il ya 13 web
elle a eu 2501 dix ans plus tard mais en
2009 il faut savoir qu'elle était très
jeune en 2007 perdant pas très jeune en
fait elle était très prometteur après la
peau mal baissé et démentent et labatut
quand elle était jeune on joue pas du
monde la zone mena match donc au delà de
80 ha oui donc en 2007 elle était très
très jeune elle doit des 89 2007 elle a
18 ans voilà dix huit ans à 2005 il est
hyper prometteur mais après elle a eu un
gros buzz mais après la remontée donc on
je crois que j'irai 2015 et 16 à 25 noms
h un kata pas le choix nous mais sa
superbe sens que ça va de manière très
acrobatique pour les noirs c'est un
mieux que tout à l'heure mais la tour f
3 va être obligé quelques comment elle
va faire kg cette tumeur as rien elle
est née en 85 à pourquoi del monte de la
joule c'était peut-être un autre tournoi
elle était hyper prometteuse en 2007 n
ya plus parler je savais qu'elle était
forte les gars étaient jeunes et tout
mais par 22 en 2005 ce que j'ai eu à
temps après et a énormément travaillé
mais reprend 1,5 à nay menace pas non je
travaille beaucoup moins que quelques
combats moi j'ai commencé à travailler
il ya cinq ans truc qui ça hein je
travaille pas pour mon affaire des gens
le comprennent pas alors attends faut
faire super gaffe maintenant parce qu'il
ya des clouage de partout et même que
cost tu peux me laisser coût des quatre
vagues jusqu'à ce que j'avais proposée
vrai mais c'est vraiment mais que pour
la peau de banane ajoutant prend un
chèque mais mes trois enfants h5 qui
menace rien cavalli ou petro way
je pense des trois segments des trois
attentats toutes les pièces dans ces
quatre 2e cat d'al mukalla me casse
matin et tour des indes à me 3 km le
cavalier façon ça sent les pieds la dame
blanche allait trop mal placé ici mais
des trois c'est vraiment forme
ouais c'est jouer sa une à temps en
temps quand on doit taper revue dames
quatre dames e3 finie et tout rires
trois dames un tout récent d'un autre
héros noir est toujours mes choix je
pense que même même plaint au delà de sa
chance même un coup comme tour ses huit
ici genre ce genre de choses as-tu
domino la dame était un peu court oui
mais bon évidemment elle a fait la malle
cattrall a gagné la partie mais c'était
juste pour dire visuellement ça se sente
et qu' il y avait un problème côté côté
kosteniuk voit et on ne s'attendait pas
qu'elle dominant troyes plus en suivait
aussi monteux et londres elle repart sur
le long de ça c'est intéressant mathieu
avait peut-être prévu un de garder le
nombre pour les cadences plus rapide que
co c'est dieu qui est pas le temps de
ouais parce que imagine tu es une petite
idée elle se dit du coup ça c est ce que
sa radio a joué coupé cinq ici aussi
sekkat donc ça date de quand la la le
match là j'en profite pour demander
sérieusement losc le bourges nayais
aussi soudaine v6 mais ça c'est un peu
dangereux
c'est la fin d'un parti à un bon niveau
c'était band forrest compte dirrig au
top 2
chaque costume qu'elle a eu un pic à 25
60 quand même hein y'a pas si longtemps
alors je crois que les deux elles ont
complètement mélanger la ligne mais ça
va revenir un truc à peu près cohérent
mais je suis sûr qu'à donner un nom
d'emprunt à 2 c sur honda bradeux dans
un autre
une position gamme a4 a6 obligé ils vont
échanger mes pains beaucoup d'aventurés
juste faire fou processus qu'elle prend
des cats
c'était une personne pour montrer le
type de position puisque du coup ça va
transpirer dans lequel cinq en dommages
d'un v6 france et 6 ça c'est un truc à
10 et les prend oui c'est ça c'est
dégueulasse pour les noirs non c'est un
peu mieux pour les blancs main mais
notre sig lors de coups pour moi il est
pas correct comme ça je me rappelle plus
des nuances on arrive dans cette
position qui est tendu ouais mais c'est
pas si simple points noirs surtout après
objectivement ça doit aller parce qu'on
va matin qu'est un dessin quant à la
paire de fou mais c'est si c'est fait
après des fois faut savoir donner un
pion mais bien les pompiers français que
tu vas voir dans le bessin qui doit être
chiant notre sens du titre en séchant
l'anpn qu'asus s'attaque là et si l
échange
tata clac attaque là donc dans ces gars
tu devrais reprendre de l'autre pour
faire aller en d6 mais du coup le mieux
c'est de jouer au jeu 3 a pris de
l'autre mais du coup elle va choquer il
décide d'emmener 5 mai les noirs sont un
peu mieux mais elle a bien joué le genre
de position après ça éclate et vraiment
pas très bien parce qu'il va faire
bouger 3 5 6 et 5
tu m'étonnes nous fait l'écart dans la
case pour le canal sagem parce que
l'autre veut faris et f6 g5 à changsha
son plan quoi elle est détonnant fort et
ça ne serait pas ça m'aurait pas
traversé l'esprit
après il ya je vais m'attaquer à ses 5
et je vais attaquer au 6 mai ça paraît
un peu abattu par peut-être un pion un
an tu parles de qui on passe à trois cas
et c'est de ta tour des 1 assure qu'il
prend tu feras québec
donc ça va
non ok kosteniuk essaie de reprendre
leur mental que c'est un mets la
pression mais c'est marrant c'est que
deux versions sont mélangés ça c'est le
dire je tourne bien tu as envie un
marcheur b4 et peut-être mètre carré y
en a cinq des cats
j ai pas conseil mais j'aurais préféré 3
est le jeu à 4 j'aurais vraiment essayé
de me ramener un cavalier mme benlabbah
taper sur ses 6 et essayer de pas si
bons mais vrai après 1,4 le jeu pour le
cas oui oui là tu veux plus pour le
contrôle de bk tu joues plus pour
essayer de vie c'est en fin de vie c'est
un cas de prises prise tour à 8 on car
jusque là bien on vous annonce est
tombée un peu gris tour à 8 direct
puisque mon effort soit de la partie je
pense que européen mais ouais non mais
ça va ça va garder un pied bien ancré
sur ce cas de dommages en fait b3 bas
juste l'a pas vu ton à cette on a un
contenu qui fait une bonne partie des
bonnes ouverte plutôt bonne ouverture
la seule façon de gagner sur pu
emprunter hisser quatre seuls 2 c'est
malin tous
elle va prendre prendre du recul c'est
calme c'est ça c'est légal pardon tour à
6 ans qui a aidé sa cause qui est b3 de
blain donc avocat lequel ces 5
c'est chaud c'est plutôt un bon coup ils
cueillent les gens retour à sept fous
des 6 3 et 7
on vole obtenir le soutien annoncé avec
les blancs quoique le tour a poussé cinq
tours v2 tour eiffel ou des trois non
moi mais je peux je fous décisif aux
autres bref des sujets 3 mieux et là tu
reviens ou la loi du faux 2,6 connu ici
je me suis calé bougeant fo et sud sur
skype russie their own cavalier rouge
j'avais pas vu cette chasse ses coups
fouet je suis ton à cette époque
beaucoup de cavaliers petits as roi des
c mathieu annoncé le pion ici ce qui est
injuste et va j'ai trouvé que laurence
et 8 à temps mais tu me lasse pas de
prendre je prends un roi de cet instant
je peux pas prendre un rouge et trois
allait compliquer cette partie avait
tendu les deux joues bien tu que le rap
il écoute à vue soit québécoise pas le
tour ou à la gueule à la rater la terre
assez terrible mais attention ces six
tours f6 bon ces tours de moins mais tu
as des pions dans trois quatre voire
quatre on sait que la devons mieux faire
la chaîne d'abord non c'est dur à dire
mathieu c'est pas clair un échec 4 6 3
je passe j'aurais peut-être fait
carrière quatre pour supprimer un
cavalier j'ai l'impression que le
cavalier va être pénible ya trop de
résonant bien joué ça ils n ont pas non
vous joue que pour l'homme à petit c'est
je trouve qu'avec peu de temps sur la
pendule c'est intéressant mais maintes
elle-même qui mieux que c'est un truc
deux ans je souhaite c'est la foire de
pau c'est la foire d'empoigné
oui wind en s'agaçant que se vouent ses
quatre roues à f2 la gauche devrait elle
a pas d'intrigué dur mais c'est dur
c'est dur c'est dur d'être fou j'ai ça
fouette 4
je les voyais plutôt jouer à age six
mois je sais pas je sais pas qui est
favorite on regrette cette position elle
est vraiment compliqué ne peut pas
échanger tour c'est chaud mais je pense
que je prendrai les blancs perçue avec
si peu de temps sur la pendule bon j'ai
vite ce fou aux 5,6 elle est tombée
c'est terrible kosteniuk n'y a plus de
2% que ans un ouais même menacé g4 aussi
peut-être dans certaines montagnes à une
tour de bois elle a rappelé gains et
gagne quand même au temps mais oui c'est
l'état raison c'est plus dur à jouer
c'était bien joué parce que les pions en
fait tu les protège suit les poussées
coup ils sont plus ou moins automatique
et kosteniuk il fallait réfléchir est
assez terrible c'est bon c'est parti de
cavaliers prend en main et finalement
elle avait bouffé des pions c'est
incroyable a l'air dépité mais tu vois
finalement toucher ni saluer la famille
la tour 3 lannion 2 cette fois pour
éviter qu'elle et ses 4
elle avait dû le voir tout à l'heure
mais c'est assez marrant quand même que
on pensait vraiment pas que le match
tourne
ça bouge chez ninacs le moins vite
qu'ils étaient dominés fac été dominés
qu'ils étaient dominés dans le petit jeu
tactique en fin de partie et puis
finalement accélération de cadence lcl
un peu accéléré le rythme aussi et puis
c'est plutôt elle qui s'en sort bien
alors là la partie précédente
honnêtement c'est que c'est nous qui la
méritent qu'on sait mieux que l'amérique
complètement plus ouais mais europe 1
c'est ça le une seconde ceinture monte
jamais un moment déjà mais des fois on
le sait fouda d'un art fois de la domine
et où elle est elle mal aussi dans ce
nom alors attends là peut-être que c'est
plus malin parce qu'elle va pouvoir fait
rage et où tout alors comment elle avait
fait pour ce faire dominé complet
la fnca l'époque elle avait la même avec
le pousse à être là le plus rangée
sicile important reste il empêche f4f
catella ya aussi ce fut le tour qui dit
que le 3ème set
un jeune cavalier aussi ce qu'a laissé
parfait qui apprend qu' on prend ça
prend un mail web search
bref cette équipe comme ça ouais je sais
tu ta tombe bien j'y allais tatouage
tanger 3 je n'aurais jamais pensé comme
vous badou battue passé le coup que vous
jouez oui naïve sahara et combien là
j aurais pas pensé je l'aurais fait à
simples souvent et c'est pris ses
quartiers dans la finale dans quasi vont
peut-être appris de mon entourage suite
franchissent chaque c'est tellement
naïve d'aller faire tous ces trucs là
avec en finale deux tours est la tête tu
as vu tout racisme et l'autre va pas
passer avec tours c'est sympa aussi
appuyé sur age 3 tablettes le droit un
jour aussi de jeu que j'aime bien tu
peux nous à 1,5 à la victoire c'est sans
doute en octobre à st je pensais que la
bid et de ces cas c'était tour c5 ou la
g400 mais la tour la tournée la croix de
jouer f5 ou quoi je lis ça je comprends
pas je pense qu'elle voulait sur f5
faire pions prend pions prends ton rêve
quatre échecs ton coin f 5 mai mais elle
cinq ans belge peut tout prendre à tous
des quatre gamins jouent un jeu peut
tout prendre eux aussi ce nom je peux
même pas vous ferez g7
je pense que c'est fantastique pour les
noirs mais bon tu peux rentrer il a
perdu tellement de temps alexandra
prises pour la rumba un taureau 4 ok tu
l'aurais jamais pansement mais joue j'ai
beaucoup de mal avec ce genre de coups
alors cela je n'en parle même pas à elle
a dû penser qu'à léger cette emprise
ouais mais elle veut trop à l'admr et
erreurs de calcul s'attaquer lato oui je
sais je sais juste pour montrer un pour
expliquer aux gens faire ce truc dont on
parle avec matthieu 7 et puis on prend
tous renvoient aux 6es apatou reprend g7
scaérois 3,5 et donc vous plat tu va
pousser le pion des surtout oui
peut-être pas gagné encore mais ça prend
forme à vis marc angers 6 juste mais j 6
je ne sais 5 boutons à chier ce look est
le fère h4 par quel point ces pilotes
le barrage 4 1 chance sur 5,5 un tour
prend et enfin l'idée c'est sûr à chaque
tour prends ton anglais on prend danger
c'est 3 is it a pas le temps de watteau
reçu en fait ce qu'elle veut parce que
ton pensée hyper fort je comprends la
scène finale deux tours tout reprend
pions prends mes passes éric lambert
mais aussi un restaurant c'est un
problème parce que ton fief est beaucoup
moins forte que tu ne seras plus rien à
la donne
je vois pas bien 4 pour attirer le droit
de l'autre côté
our wild 2 n'ont pas une grande finale
deux tours ans à la hache 4 3 3
aujourd'hui je pense on le 3 quelque
chose soit fait rage
c'est au nom des 500 m 1 non c'est pas
bon surtout reprend h3 tu vas faire ton
5e h1 et là je pensais tour des 5
mais bon peugeot lâche 2000 à 135 pour
le pillage d'un roi des deux obligé
qu'elliott pour acheter trois fuites à
gaydon mal joué là non ouais après tant
mieux pour que l'otan prenne pas de
points 9
oui oui prétendu jamais à
hô-chi-minh-ville et trois de suite
quasiment nous nombre a quasiment
carrément carrément elle aurait pu faire
4-1
impossible à trouver la chaîne numéro ce
ça va être
sharma et rock'n'roll ou quelque chose
comme ça c'est pas facile à trouver
donc foulée 6 ou g iii par exemple
changer un en pensait que c'était mieux
pour le blanc car et lieusaint 4 4 ah
non ça je conseille pas bons par l'idée
bonne frange et trois non non non max
les blanches fed à me2 ce maroc cela
s'avère pour les noirs sa cavale le
simple qui fait l'âme ses statuts force
f qu'as-tu fait qu'elles cèdent qui
aiment s'en fout et celles qui décident
qui inquiète le plan un peu peut-être le
montrer avoir lieu adams dans ton mais
normalement tu es censé provoquer et
c'était la recommandation d'un groupe
dans son lit et bien il ya six ans mais
il a fait ses preuves c'est le bon blanc
parle située qu'à tu peux pas le montrer
son sassa instructif tu fais 5e pole de
philosophe
c'est comme ça quand même elle faisait
qu'appliquer des six
j'ai cinq cahiers feuilles ou n'importe
quel couple hercules et ça ça va même si
c'est tout et c'est même le prénom
chèque mais trois cas normal non ouais
ça chez mme demierre passe une fois h4
et je suis content
on serait échangée peut-être quatre ex
changer quoi angers 6 c'est triste tout
les deux
après le têt requête pensez pas être mue
elle a réussi à reprendre de f
c'est pas possible je renvoie en fait à
dresser juste terrible non mais ça c'est
juste pas possible non
le camion gros fonds seront donc
reprendre
et pas n'importe quoi prends moi je
pensais troupe rend fou prend m6 dans
quel point qu'elle en neuf ans tout sera
un point c'est tout
mais c'est fantastique sont rares ce
carré fait dans la partie mais c'est
incroyable ça c'est une bonne idée ce
truc que cal fawcett
sauf que normalement c'est avec eux pas
comme ça après il a réussi deux
placements qui avait acheté au bon
moment et on est d'accord c'est un peu
trop tarabiscoté sanaa où china cligne
des yeux pas trop près du lit ce point
son nom mais c'est étonnant
j'ai une question pour le chat est ce
que vous savez quel est l'enjeu du match
en termes d'argent quand tu ne joues tu
apprends nous à prendre là il ya pas mal
d'argent jeu quand même pour ce match
oui ça m'a non ceni 312 ni 20 mines
n'est pas un mignon et ses 3000 aurait
en réalité on a une gagnante et la
perdante l'a dit la différence entre les
deux prix est de 3000 1 la gagnante
gagne 6500 et la perdante 3500 il ya dix
mille dollars en jeu là les 10 15 c'est
pas mal c'est pas mal
et dis toi que pour se qualifier là tous
les tournois y avait des prix genre le
projet précité 3000 et 3
mi 2000 1700 semble pas sa 200ème
universelle qui va gagner le tournoi
empochera plus de bien plus de dix mille
dollars bat largement ok c'est facile à
l'afp ousseni of china kosteniuk elle a
pris 3 milles au dernier et les deux
autres elle a fait six points dont elle
a pris mille donc elle va faire trois
mille 1000 milles et c'est le gagne 6511
1500 c'est pas mal mais c'est pas non
plus extravagants non non ça me fait un
bon mois d'août par rapport au pas par
rapport aux échecs mixte c'est quand
même bien moindre
oui oui on dit que 10000 c'est quand
même 800 mille rôle ouimet kosteniuk
elle vit pas en russie n'en est bien
pareil donc un les noirs sont à peu près
sorti fondé 6/9 étaient quatre en fait
tu force le cook et non anglais de jouer
mais bon bricolage attaqué sur ses 5 au
retour français 6 juillet 201 pour pas
grand chose maintenant vous le train
tour au 5 mai pour le sait pas à quel
point c'est vrai mais on oublie que cela
ne disait qu'un gros défaut de beaucoup
de joueurs c'est qu'ils avaient du mal à
avoir les couilles voulait jouer leurs
adversaires mois - c'est un peu j'ai
quand j'étais jeune je me trouvais
rapide maintenant je suis assez lent
pour voir les trucs et emmené en partie
longue il faut que je prenne mon temps
pour bien calculé pour voir découvrir
tous les ans glisse maintenant et c'est
devenu un point que je vois beaucoup
moins vite qu'un tu vas peut-être des
choses différentes quoi moi je comprends
mieux ce qui se passe mais je joue moins
bien maintenant votre nom même nom c'est
de les blancs peuvent plus être mieux
parce que leurs qualités de et faibles
peuvent pas être moins bien non plus une
en hiver ils peuvent même être mieux
encore ceux ci viennent ces cinglés
juste le pion à vii c'est moins grave
que de thalassa genève 7,4 en jeu si
c'est moins grave
ça doit être ça va être mais après this
way la tour bleue quand même le roi noir
qui est plus coupées
comprends pas bonjour baby 3 3 3 3 4 4 l
3 bien jouer nombreuses tarifs gestion
du coup t'es pas un mauvais coup 7la
hall alors assez terrible c'est la
deuxième fois qu'elle nous fait ça ouais
mais là c'est beaucoup quand même
pour m6 qui avait lieu 4 c'est dur quand
même si sylvain daury non mais bon ok ça
ça ça arrive à tout le monde mais quand
même le faire deux fois en deux heures
c'est beaucoup moins grosse boulette
alors je sais pas honnêtement le choix
là de thiès queen de rentrer dans sa
sauf si sauf celles à une idée très
précise et joue pas la vente la plus
solide avec les noms et joue le pion
isolé ça peut être intéressant c'est une
égalisation des points de la part de la
joueuse russe
mathieu set partout un sushi nina qui
est pour moi c'est un choc
bizarre de sa porte parce que je trouve
que je mûris plus solides 1,4 c'est pas
le met un coup dont claude mais ça c'est
assez intéressant parce que là tu as
essayé de l'attaquer comme une brise au
les uns mais est-ce qu'elle a toutes les
clés
ça a l'air d'être pas mal pour les noirs
quand même à mettre en place
ashiru bessède et des cinq mais toujours
dangereux alors pourquoi à 4 c'était pas
terrible ben la voilà vous avez la case
b4 là demain disent ne pas faire un
carton facile tu vas faire là car dans
ces trucs là parce que tu peux pas
donner la carte b4 ses seins et b5 c'est
moins grave parce qu'on fait dans tous
les cas le fou soir son but 7-6 en
groupe des six ou pas ce qu'il faut
faire à troyes b 5 x 2 si tu as envie
est tellement envie toute façon de
partir là bas pour avoir les deux
diagonales ou en d3 d'abord mais c'est
pareil ça comme tu veux mais tout ça
pour dire que kaka est la seule ligne
qui existe mais c'est là dans la slave
met à un tank us ce qu'il fait c'est 6
pouces est simple donc les noirs la
jouer à 15
on déclare salah qui est exactement la
même bon après ça reste compliqué hein
ça reste impuni zone il ya du dynamisme
donc qu'ils allaient prendre cette le
cake appel à tout ce que je veux dire
c'est bien roulé ça il faut aussi se
débarrasser donc à 6,6 kg 6 pour se
débarrasser de ce qu'est venu aux 5 jean
paray que notre adversaire est forte on
essaye de parler non plus tôt pour kg 6
personnes parce que si elle prend je
prends de la chute d'un peu mieux sur
carte blanche sous peu aux points soit
juste à regarder la colonne âge mais ça
on et ça paraît loin du torrent h 30 ne
marche pas non mais non mais qui sait si
c'est davantage d'attaqués des cas de
dengue a été un peu pris force en
mettant la tombe de cavale est en fait
la version plus directe qui avait les
f-5 le laisse loin du founan - le mans
du fou je me que meilleure viande et 5
ouais ok les stores h3 bon ça c'est
dangereux parce qu'elle ramène pas du
tout pièces en défense f5 un polo rayé
les l5 et alan ya quatre ans c'était
n'importe quoi il ya quelque chose qui a
qui a mal tourné là pour pour les noirs
ton jeu je passe bien tant g3
d'investissement juste keller quatre
parkings 5 ces tapages et 6,6 avec les
pros way dont j'ai trois assez fort
temps pour montrer tout le prince si
c'est tentant mais il y avait cinq buts
à mach 4 tempo bien joué 20 matches 4
cavale et f4 d'accord elle rejaillit ci
qui est des cinq balles jaunes secousse
j'imagine aussi mais ça non il ya
d'hommes des trois tours dès 8 h 1 300
jeux qui est en fait elle a échangé le
mauvais cavaliers ou au mauvais endroit
la finance et 6 battu en fait ce qui
embête 4 qu'il est beau un moment donné
mais après quand il ya moins de cas sur
l'échiquier il est censé revenir
ah ouais autant mourir le ventre plein
non je pense qu'elle veut pousser de en
vrai c'est 5 à 4 oui mais bon dans ses
rangs au coude avant il n'y a pas tant
pranger c'est 3 prouvent qu'ils avaient
les à chaque dame prend un schiste est
pas mal d'infos pas ça marche c'est pas
facile parce que là tu penses que tu es
gagnant méthode elle a eu l à une minute
trente
l agent combien de temps elle a réfléchi
plus pour h4 que cameron c'est un peu
dommage bon à l'autre szczesny n'a du
coup elle défend je quitte c'est moche
ce qu'on peut faire un autre âge et pas
de 15 tours b 5 sél est tombé cinq
dessins qui on coupe la traverse et
après on prend le 5 est ce que tu peux
pas trop où j'allais dire bref fuite
mais ça va pas du tout quant à martine
francke et ouais mais bon j'avais trouvé
6 kg 6 non non c'est pas ça à l'air
d'être terrifiant non mais tu en vises
un tu es mouvaux quoi bon choix de
costumes ou de changer pour le cap que
lo jo ce pion ou alors elle peut jouer
son jeu d'attaqué même si c'est pas
correct a peut le faire un peu joué son
jeu vers l'avant en 30 minutes bâle en
plus elle va reprendre alors reprendre
l'avantagé dans le match c'est dommage
de tourner ce petit bout hisser ces
graines
grosse erreur un call a fait toucher
nina cry 2 c'est jusqu'à quelle heure je
crois que c'est juste je peux aller plus
téléphoner je crois que c'est jusqu'à 50
jusqu'à 51 ou 52 j'ai regardé quand ça a
commencé
donc il reste encore 20 minutes tu
penses donna je sais que c'est mon choix
est fait exprès à cesser ces cailloux 5
d'abord on est alors la c4 ici
d'apprendre des cats et le court mais
qui verse des jeux ça non ça c'est
possible aussi pris ses six semaines on
sait ce que toi tu américain oui mais
s'étaient trompés dans leurs deux
courses c'est ce que j'explique mais
elle va pas faire pour commencer si ce
qui est dépensé 4 pourtant c'est là
j'étais mauvaise langue mais après est
censé connaître et joe cole elle ajoute
que ça tout le tournoi et c'est
d'ailleurs il doit y avoir une partie
contre comme sarah dans une tracy mullin
rock et celle là ceux qui aiment bien
meilleure version que ce qu'elle a eu
tout à l'heure sympa pour les blancs ça
puisque le pion c6 il est bien sous
pression après fait pas non plus la fin
du monde mais en général qui met un
cahier le 3 nuits en trois temps anciens
et une tempête un peu le ton du reste ce
que faisait cinq sièges propre en moi ça
peut l'être défauts mais il réfléchit
trop l'un torcéen c'est en plus hyper
logique dans laquelle trône où je serai
qu'il ya eu trois mois je trouve 5e 3
c'est qu'ils me garderaient thème pour
vraiment et qu'intel trois fous des 5
ce n'était pas grave
la jeu à trois je te faire bander 8
d'autres jeux beckett mais ça se passe
de 5 à 3 j'aurais pas fait mais bon je
ne sais pas si c'est parce que
maintenant qu'elle sait si ce qu'on
montre que je fais peccata cat
là encore ça prescott
oui mais malheureusement elle n'est pas
dans les temps non où elle est dans les
temps pour faire 3 8 à 4 tours ces huit
bekkat à l'epo cera kat direct ouais
mais je voulais faire pour sauver quatre
ans b 5 mai à la ja des quatre noms des
quatre des cinq bonniers se disputent
avantage plan là clair parce que le voir
plus le ce1 saguenay d'un nom yacoub et
6 qui étaient allés à 5 pouces et ça
traîne ça gagne la dame comme ça le
voile en règle avec maintenant un
nouveau pas sur le jeu dingue de tous
ces éléments ne faut pas ça elle
n'arrive pas à switcher en mode saas et
élémentaire quand même costume je sais
pas si elle a vu ou pas si alors que
c'est lui qui l'a vu à la penderie tempo
égalisation non c'est un beau match
comme on est on a de la chance c'est
serré si j'avais peur d'un sens unique
au début là c'est hyper serré 8 partout
je vais je vais à l'essai de choper on
va pas voir l'échiquier pendant deux
secondes le temps d'étaler de choper le
temps way par par curiosité
intellectuelle mathieu ça devient chaud
qui reste combien de temps alors attends
c'est par ici
c'est terrible ce que sémou gichuki qui
commentant ces seize minutes web facile
parce qu'elle joue à jouer le tournoi
c'est terrible quand tu l'endroit de
commenter la finale voit la main de ba
était proche
non c'était étonnant d'ailleurs un musou
je la voyais plus forte
ouais mais je l'avais juin rapide au cap
d'agde elle m'avait pas impressionné le
trou trop lente
pas forcément mais dont les huit élégant
comme ça ce qui est procession français
cizia pas d'un premier quatre noms
continuent qu'elle a vécu en suisse mais
il ya plus de dix ans il avait même un
appart à miami à moscou madame 3,24 je
vous laisse calculer nos pays à
n'importe qui mais quand j'ai du tueur
être calculé ça peut marcher zone de 4,6
g soit j'aurais fait partie voilà tu
auras d1 du coup tant que joueur de
scandinaves le dame prend des 4 me tente
est quand même obligé pas eu de problème
[Musique]
donc escale à la nationalité française
non cotée de suisse oui mais française
non non pas à cause ainsi ce serait venu
fawcett bout d'un moment il faut quand
même nous des clous et arrêtez un peu
l'économie city j'ai pu enfin cette
emprise je n'ai pas de sit in à bien
protéger ses petits pions c'est papa
fois que nous fait un petit à six
cavaliers e400 salaire d'appoint ne sera
pour tout le monde ça peut vraiment
jouer dans le pull est ma ba ouai bah
tant mieux donc du coup c'était quoi le
16 minutes
il reste seize minutes donc 16 minutes
trois parties sûrement en compte en
salle la salle un bon look et liam byrne
que c'est un poids énorme mais on a un
mauvais fou donc ça le problème c'est
quand les blancs vont regagner ses six
le fou qui était mauvais il va redevenir
bon donc on va être ça peut être juste
égal moi je donne ensuite je prends les
noirs ici sans hésiter
je suis très heureux d'être là mais là
il a loupé cette main parce que dans
trente ou h2o dams et rend compte des
deux vraiment les noirs christ en croix
souper 3 comment ça marche dames c'est
un genou oui ça je n'ai pas vu
évidemment tu me l'as dame s'est
renfermé la tour mais n'ont même pas
être heureux mais qui a commencé à se
poser les questions à toi tu as plus
fous 17 à 3 mais à trois c'est attendait
d'eux tant qu'on métro tu perds la calme
mais toro 2 ce que tu ressors venu j'ai
l'impression que oui c'est artistique
nous c'est peut-être bien jusque dans le
sac en fait ça défend décès c'est
surtout qui est vrai que si tu arrives à
ressortir par la tuer quand tu mettras
de flamber sais tu seras un je pense que
les blancs doivent essayer d'arriver
plus tôt sur hkd à kf3 ou non mais du
coup ça doit aller et chômage en plus un
bon tournoi seul coup ouais sauf ces
données à tour un f3 tour h4 va la
sortir par à 6 et vous comment elle et
blanc se lance en mieux tu pars en h4
parents réussissent à un pion de +36
peut pas prendre des quatiers flash est
le classique g3 je pense pas très envie
t'auras chunk comment d'amd sur dès
maintenant on attaque la tour des huit
ambulances tour j'aurais fait demander
s'il se souvient d'une époque ce qu'est
le tour h5 c'est pas mal et 3 5 1 qui
arrive tu attaques par la tude et
prendra là c'est toute la partie tu
joues avec un flou - mais bon à la fin
si sensible au kenya partie en f3 le
prince et que ton roi était faible
yahvé g2 qui pouvait traîner pour
apprendre à renault
chorus un bon bah écoute là ça va être
un pion de plus âpre et sfr vous prend
vous prend et dessins ce que j'ai l'air
peut-être que le nord devait jeu des 50
prophylaxie 5 pour éviter de deux parce
qu'en fait des cats et une faiblesse et
la macif et des 5 a elle fait pas non
mais là je fais j'ai six des 5 tu vis ou
alors assisté colin mais c'est bizarre
de parents venus des cinq c'était
tellement logique surtout donne force et
non mais ça ça va ça oui mais bon on a
quand même le droit de on dit ça parce
qu'en fait si on arrive à jeu des cinq
et qu'on échange raconte b on va gagner
des cats et la finale avec deux points
de plus et gagnante assez facile donc
ici celle là elle est moins facile parce
que des saints qui va être une idée je
m'engage à le lan vrai je pense je pas
sûr parce qu'en fait le point qu'elle
est rarement bon alors il faut mieux
l'avoir dans l'autre sens mais peut-être
que priest tu peux joseph cinq médailles
du coup c'est la race prendre des six du
coup ça va être le cap contre on oui
c'est nul théorique mais font encore
ouais mais plutôt un bon choix
faut pas quelqu'un de sa tour le truc
c'est que là le purifient 4 il est pas
mal placé dans lequel sont tombés cette
la tombe et 7 pour les blancs non je
n'étais pas ironique tonnes voilà il ya
tourbe est ce parce que sinon je te fait
roi m5 et m6 comme ça c'est nul nul mais
a je crois bien joué la g4g troyat tour
d2 non c'est pas nouveau non j'ai deux
tours 2 j'aime bien mais tu fais comment
pour amener ton roi du fairway f5 tout
reprend rage et quatre peut-être 3,8
google serait parti pour revivre 5 1
sache que c'est dommage ouais mais c'est
le roi jean iii g5 qui veut faire f5
d'abord qu'est tous rêvent de l'ain
seront fait chasser ces choix les f-5 se
saluer les packs à dos 1 elle est pas du
tout cas d'auto non mais tu as peut-être
des plans comme ça il m'est ont pu
manger s'attend à tomber trois paroisses
g4 c'était très fort non on tombe est
retombé de touche finale au cube ah oui
ait envie trois tombes et de pardon
excuse moi mathieu j'avais pas vu non
plus c'est pas toi qu'as tu n'en aurait
que normalement c'est indéfendable
ok il faut qu'elle fasse le plan pour la
finale de pions et voyager 4 c'est un
voyage et 504 et tour quatre matches
elle a gagné en fait c'était sa seule
façon de gagner c'était de matériel
acheté depuis elle a raté la tourache
aimé la gagner c'est du trois plus un
rond et elle mène maintenant mathieu 9 8
9 à 8
il reste elle a duré longtemps cela non
mon avis il en reste encore deux quand
même parce que 16 minutes la partie
avait déjà commencé
[Musique]
quoique on comprend un temps réfléchi là
tu peux pas rentrer dans ce site a plus
d'idées b5
mais je vous ferai a mouché nina
légèrement supérieur à mathieu lavallée
hausse mais là elle a repris la
ressemblance qu'au début non mais c'est
4 je répète le meilleur cours d'un
premier quart mais bon c'est un peu
dangereux ou francis et ses concurrents
ce cas de ces corps elle donc c'est bien
phu processus qui allait prendre un
petit rock juste tout à l'heure bella
elle avait dominé assez facile donc à
quatre c'est sa partie contre
non mais c'est pas dans la même position
à la joue à quatre contre
on saura ce que la dame prend des quatre
pieds processus dames 3 4
c'est ça existe à 4 sais pas si belle
île foulée 4 rock well as modifié mais
d'un prince et kate à s'élancer sur moi
elle mais ça c'est pas c'est ainsi
c'était pas si contente d'apprendre et
de et après je vais recommencer si ce
qui est conséquente mais bon pas non
plus la fin du monde fou prend ses six
français quatre cases des six l'âge
allait facilement d'un je vais établir
plus facilement un truc intéressant qui
avait y en a cinq
l'ancien clan beckham ça s'appelle
dangereux c'est un peu mieux pour les
blancs ça c'est sûr une nouvelle fois
mathieu bref c'est assez bien jouer de
nouveau le pion sait si c'est un peu
faible et george iii va de son p'tit
coup la mirage iii b 4 en général c'est
ça qu'il menaçait donc soit tu bouges
tadam sodome et 3 de phoebé 84 sont trop
réfléchir donc l'un s'est s'inquiété
possible temps reprend avec eric est toi
qui es 5 j'aime pas trop parce que le
cahier des fois il y en a cinq
sa position tout à l'heure à la bouffe
et la dame en classe mais après la
matrice les moins peuvent essayer
d'attaquer vite que puis un becquet
parce qu'on n'a pas de tomber ça s'est
plutôt bien passé bien joué
c'est un tour 6-4 et en c1
on sentait en option ça existe et c'est
peut-être pas mal c4est un pokémon non
tous ces quatre c'est bien joué sur ces
quatre c'est très bien joué lès tours
c'est un qui arrive à kosteniuk en
difficulté un vrai temps de repasser un
pour attaquer à celle valverde des 4
mais devait perdre prenons nous voilà et
gigote et toi en fait elles y ont enlevé
ces de son type de position ça fait un
moment qu'elle appelle atteint qu'à part
le dans midam accepter la callas gagné
d'ailleurs facilement oui
quant à elle a pu attaquer 1,5
c'est un peu le problème de casting
comme s'il jouait très directs sur des
matches longs si tu réussis à lui
enlever ces attaques elle peut se perdre
après ça c'est bien joué quand même pas
ce qui a pu agacer 4 comme tout à
l'heure je pense qu'à un moment alors
attaqué ces quatre intermédiaires je
suis quasiment sûr bon là je pense faut
quand même faire thierry ckt changer si
je vous la tour c 5 quand même ouais il
faut des trois tours c'est simple ouais
torcéen le fond des singles en fait il
est beau mais a fait le fleuve 4 il a
son répondant ce qui n'empêche orbite
mais peut-être un jour d'hui pas du
bessat tu feras dubé cinq exactement et
et la diagonale on peut l'affirmer ok en
f3 un jour peut-être pas tout de suite
moi je préfère tout le temps et toujours
les blancs d'hommes c3 geoffrey alors
voilà c'est genre de positions que je
joue avec les blancs justement que c'est
souvent très optimiste que les premium
et au quai seynois joue bien après
peut-être comment tu va attaquer je
demande à voir
mais ça c'est sûr c'est ça je me lasse
b55 à tord à lui seul coup à toi un vide
seul coup face au gaz
mais du coup c'est le coup donc bien
jouer tu auras 8
mais bon maintenant c'est déjà parce
qu'on a tout fait avec les blancs mais
on n'arrive pas à passer ça non mais nul
ça serait très bien quatre tours n'a
plus un rond les bulles est prêt à y
avoir beaucoup de bulletins dans cette
cadence si on a il y en a peut-être
fuite
c'est combien de bill est une minute
trente minutes par ci un peu beaucoup
un peu chaud non mais ce serait chaud
par rapport à l'original alors dit
comprendre des 5
c'est beau c'est le trou c'est une
bouffée un but en fait y'a un truc assez
logique dans l'esprit bonbons nature
entre ou oui bon tu rentres nulle part
mais bon elle voulait rentrer dans le
court maintenant c'est les noirs sont
bien basse et une noire qu'ils vont
attaquer avec le foot et 5 oui on va te
change pas les plaindre et je prends ça
devrait être ça devrait faire un nul
quand même beau temps je pense juste
c'est quoi cette partie on n'est pas je
sais pas qui tu entends vrai ouais c'est
ça c'est ça exactement moins vite et si
j'ai pu enfin pour moi c'est les noirs
qui ont en leur interdisant d'un match
est pas mal l'international français 2
dames c'est cette dame f5 peut-être d'un
machin 37 secondes grâce à là ça peut
finir 1 n'a pas le choix pour revenir
après trois dessins guider ce qu'on
mangeait soit c6 trop si c'est du coup
avec le fou de cases noires et le pion
pour la qualité
l'ordinateur mais l'heure du décès de
très fort mais du coup c'est une erreur
peut-être fallait aller à f/5 tu avais
raison
parce qu'il n'y a pas là mais cette y
avait deux français deux fois elle
revient mais maintenant il y en a eu
quatre attentats 4,1 me
9 50 mais bon dans le droit ou un seul
coup mais là tu vois tout de suite oh là
là mais elle a quel était mon bien en
temps à epagny bons fous des six pouces
et 5
d'après les noirs sont communes
légèrement salée noir qui et c'est quoi
non c'est bien joueurs au f4 ya plus de
bons ça fait nul mathieu huit et demi
n'a fait 2008 et demi je pense qu'il
faut qu'elle tourne avec un mois je
pense qu'il faut qu'il joue avec +2 ou
+3 juste deux parce que alexandra elle
m'a l'air d'être quand même plus après l
homme à l a fait 2-2 près nouveau
s'était même pas des primes aux
impressions quant à l'aller les citoyens
présents ont changé de ligne c'est la
dernière de cette cadence mathieu blin
la prochaine journée
alors j'ai toujours pensé que c'était
une pas une bonne une pour les noms mais
je reviens plus ah ouais c'est par amour
fou fou et ça je suis pas sur ce seul
moyen qu'elle prenait ce dessin qui ces
colis des ouh là l'homme ci ne pourrait
pas réaliser c'est quelqu'un qui est
prêt à taux réduit et 6,7 à la fin ça
c'est sûr et c'est peut-être gagnants
n'ont ils pas du tout recueil des cinq
alarmant qu'est ce que c'est que ce
bordel
key ces 507 à reprendre cette ouais si
le clan jusqu'à et d4 kf5 entreprise est
ça le tempo choc c'était le projette sur
la base du projet déjà crucial non mais
tu restes tu reste très bien avec les
blancs juste annonce qu'elle va égaliser
iker caps 1 tu peux pas tuer quelqu'un
de kf 5e quoi qu'il en est mais au coude
à coude avant la pause avant je sais pas
si ça marchait ok on va voir ce qu'elle
fait ou chez nina c'est une bonne
question vous pensez quoi l'idée
d'allonger la finale moi je trouve que
si j'ai moi moi je trouve que de a à z
tout était trop long en fait donc la
longe et ben disons que en réalité si tu
fais tout le tournoi avec des formats
comme ça mais que tu en fais qu'un ça
fait peut-être sens mais le fait que le
temps était déjà tellement allongé sur
la longueur qu'en fait très allongé
encore la finale tu as l'impression que
tout est long en vrai ce que je sais
c'est trop long après c'est les nerfs
entre enjeux sociologiques j'aime bien
par rapport aux autres qu'à ses cours là
il ya les nerfs il ya l'ascendant dans
les ouvertures c'est pas forcément la
meilleure chose qui peut gagner derrière
du coup j'aime bien en fait d'avoir une
finale longue après fallait peut-être
peut-être trois semaines de moins de
compétition quoi donc les blancs sont
clairement mieux que de lacazette 5 et
monstrueuse le pion celle ci c'est une
épine un avis mais c'est pas encore
gagnant et les noirs ou aux joueurs
assez vite voir ça je comprends pas je
pense qu'elle est vraiment un unique
pièce mais bon il ya tant points réussis
elle a raté trois points leur
intermédiaire ouais bon ça commence à
craquer physiquement là mathieu web est
lassé les nerfs
allez un petit plein damas huit dames
achète dans la bo de munich ont 30 et
3,8 en plus réticents ou chez nina ricci
mena à la salle est sympa c'est que
dalle machette
elle a tellement souffert un martini
franchement ça c'est je trouve qu'elle a
des plans agréable ou chez nina non mais
ils changent et changent c'est la finale
doit pas être si des gamins n'ont
maintenant plus le pion peuple est
retombé à tabac jeux de finale paraît
quand même ça j'aurais fait exactement
ça wajih 8 mai sur case blanche ou alors
des maxis tu contrôler quasiment pour
t'éviter de te prendre un truc un jour
paul v 5 pour essayer d'échanger et
jouer la colonne ça m'a fait parce que
les cinq hommes et cinq essais cinq bien
cinq dames des cats bien je suis
d'ailleurs c'est bien le way ma les deux
joues bien mais b5 et c5 tour g4 ça va
être ça la partie par revenir sur six
peut-être ouais mais arrête des cinq n'a
pas envie mais lorsque je vois pas
d'autres coûts que ces cinq baies prend
b5 ccg un truc tu peux perdre de ma cage
des quêtes
enfin tout le monde à perdre et tout le
monde peut perdre mathieu pour notre
bonhomme on ne comprend pas trop leurs
idées dans le format est un peu étonnant
après j'ai compris pourquoi ça finissait
à lundi la journée internationale des
échecs ils ont voulu finir là-dessus
après je trouve ça un peu là encore un
peu et en jeu à titre perso parce que
c'est pas un jour férié donc pas fini de
manger quoi qu'il en soit fatwa nom âge
c'est parce que je leur reproche le plus
vous dire non mais je trouve qu'il ya
que des décisions majeures sont qu'à
chaque fois que tu as un col 50/50 d'un
col il est toujours du mauvais côté quoi
d'hectares colle un peu compliqué
chanson que la mauvaise décision est
prise
bondoukou tour 8 c'est cette science art
qui est mieux je penche pour la loire
parce que les pions sont blancs nés pour
aller taper
oui mais nîmes fort de la guerre
toujours faut toujours avoir son revers
e8 pour faire gaffe au courant des six
mais si tu échanges tout je pense que
les blancs gagne pain noir gagne pain
viennois regagnerait c'est sûr enfin
sauf les pièces mineurs je garde les
cavaliers fou tu gagnes cet échange les
pièces mineurs ça dépend où sont les
rois parce qu'il ya les normes en la
rupture de 5 assez bien c'est bizarre
des talents g7 et pendant ces 5 avec le
quéré oui
et du coup les blancs ont gagné elle va
égaliser du coup ça a joué je suis
pessimiste fébé si soudain me prend 1,25
je pense tu prends à cinq des six puis
en france et c'est 3,17 à prendre l'a5
et maintenant je rêvais 6 puis en
prendre non amélioration princes 4 et
puis on prend h4 maladresse que j'allais
dire tu dois pas être changé les dames
parce que sinon tu gagnes tu prends h4
il va commencer leur fuite
c'est peut-être plus tôt les noirs qui
gagne mathieu monde et 6.1 ça s'échauffe
[Musique]
en même temps tu me mets à échanger les
dames ici de 8,7 à 4006
ces quatre derniers une course comme ça
te rappelle des bleus on gagne c'est la
même en fait f6 forcé elle va regagner
ou là ou là haut le n'importe quoi
il y avait des hommes français 6
bêtement non mais y avait ces deux
tableaux dames watts en fait voir ces
deux c2c cette dame mais c'est la même
ouais d'un méchant mais c'est terrible
moi j'avais vu d'armes français 6 ans et
6 pas mal j'ai pas vu ou athènes de 5 à
sas est elle assez terrible
comment tu fais dames 5 et dames aussi
c'est horrible aussi d'un v6 de costing
soldats français 3 la wii
le français 3 avant un c'est pas avant
nous bams et s'être encore ça gigote
mais c'est incroyable a salué me reste
que trois secondes on comprend il n'y a
pas de preuve mais juste heureux c'est
ouf
ah non on aurait pu faire la même la
même connerie c'est pour ça qu'on pense
qu'on bullet kosteniuk est favorite oui
parce qu'elle va gagner ce genre de choc
- dans ces moments là we fight choc au 6
mai à louviers chérèque plus ouais moi
mais du coup c'est serré c'est cool du
coup ça a tout joué sur son début l'aide
sur le bullet way manières rudes on se
fait une petite pause ouais mais ça
marche à tout gérer à tout de suite
ouais moi aussi je leur ai fait une
petite pause les gars je vous emmène à
leur passe à dar partie on se retrouve
dans moins de cinq minutes à tous si
tout le monde
les amis je suis revenu mathieu va
bientôt revenir lui aussi donc il y aura
les bulles est un pur pour se départager
égalité parfaite entre les entre les
deux femmes neuf et demi on a fait demi
ça ne pouvait pas être plus serré il
semble que kosteniuk soit favorite ans
l'a senti pendant le match en bullet
mais après après avoir un donc moi je
serais sûrement live après sur ma chaîne
perso je vais dîner puis j'aurais
sûrement live tête pour les pistes
partie pédagogique mais pas forcément
très longtemps il ya eu beaucoup de
leïla en plus aujourd'hui live voulons
un ca à faire un live de deux quasi
quatre heures déjà donc on verra ça et
je demandais à ma mathieu si tu veux
faire des parties pédagogique vendredi
si on va en profiter quand il va revenir
ça fera plaisir
mais quel homme je vais essayer de faire
1406 je peux aujourd'hui a demandé à
mathieu ci peut être dispo dès mercredi
on sera moins qu'ils feraient la master
class sur les rois actifs en finale live
1 heure où je sais pas exactement date
un peu plus tard mathieu était dispo
vendredi pour des parties pédagogique
éventuellement je te soutiens possibles
composants parce que les gens les gens
les gens tu manques tu nous manques quoi
ça fait longtemps que j'ai regardé ça
fait trois semaines oui bah déjà la
master class mercredi prochain ça c'est
pas ce mercredi-là l'autre d'après ya eu
le 29
j'avais noté le cercle rouge pas en
vacances en août ce que je t'avais dit
d'ailleurs j'ai d'ailleurs je passerai
de voir comme si ce n'est pas au courant
non mais je suis au courant mais tu
passeras tu passeras dans le studio
je pense à demain il ya mais demain il
ya mazet qui s'est basé qui vient dans
le dans le studio pour le title ok cool
israël sera là-bas depuis le temps du
coup vendredi tu veux n'aurait à
vendredi ce serait sympa ça ferait
plaisir à tout le monde d'accord
non non non non c'est bon on se tient au
courant après mai mais mercredi c'est
moi du coup qui fait la master-class je
leur faire une master class sur les rois
qui monte en finale je leur montrais une
partie qui valait choqué georges je
pourrai montrer short mais ces milieux
de jeu mais je pourrais la montrer pour
rigoler je vais montrer qu'il est
atteint de pièces que ça oui je sais je
sais je vais montrer thalys it's in un
roi qui part de c1 qui arrive en d2
c'est 3 des 4 5 des 6 et 7 17 à 7
là tu leur spoil ouais bon elle règle
quand le thème de la maturité ces
montres leroy qui t'attend bien que non
mais l'idée c'est que c'est une partie
qui est un peu choquant parce que le
plan est un peu failli les marques en
mai c'est pour s'en rappeler en fait
c'est fait exprès m'ad'ailleurs mares
faudrait que je trouve une idée pour
mastercard jaune d'oeuf georges et
d'autres partis à moi mais je me dis
peut-être mixer aussi avec des parties
d'ordi longtemps alors il est parti de
rien on adore
mais j'avais pris un pied à faire
tellement par contre j'avais beaucoup
travaillé parce que des bases du coup
sûr j'avais beaucoup préparé après les
gens adorent rien je peux te dire
qu'elle a eu des nerd excellent mais
j'étais content parce que c'est une des
vidéos que j'ai fait clairement le plus
de commentaires à les gens vraiment
beaucoup aimé vrai même si tu te
l'attendait pas forcément
honnêtement j'étais content de ce que
j'avais fait mais tu sais pas bon alors
mais tu on retourne à nos moutons on en
reparlera après on retourne dans le but
l'attaquant mathieu favorite
favorite dans le kosteniuk on va voir
j'ai cinq sets pour moi qui était plus
logique mais j'ai toujours trouvé ça
dangereux stratégiquement un canard mais
c'est intéressant
généralement ils font ça et parce qu'il
peut avoir des g4 icontrol lacazette 4
mai savane on suppose que vous la sacem
bizarre bon message ou un f4 non d'alger
5 à 4 oui enfin je rêve katenko comme ça
oui
après peut-être qu'ils attaquent qui est
activée je reprends agents après avec
l'autre mais j'aurais pris comme ça
ouais j'aime bien les flatteries h assez
bien joué ça les mêmes caillage
quatrième blessure l'a fait à mme 2 x 6
km 2 x 6 à 4 est bien jeune arrière de
même à chaque j'aime bien ce que
maintenant tout contrôlé à cache-cache
4c de l'eau est lâché un petit fou à 6
mais c'est envers les positions que j'ai
souvent à la carte b4 à saint quay prend
il ya tout reprend hayden besson c'est
le matin league oui tu t'appelles pas
besoin de perdre de temps je pensais pas
de mauvais coups j'aurais pris aussi
parce que cavaler fh cats à l'heure de
guinée tout de suite c'est
extraordinaire là ce qu'elle fait
mikhaël hers cats étaient rideau un
ouais mais ça me paraît rigaud aussi un
hoquet fremm bosser encore mais sinon
des cinq stratégiquement ainsi des cinq
un coup sega je tends ferme le faux avis
ouais mais tu t'enfermes le x 6 aussi
ses cheveux d'amd 2 mai cavaliere fait
h4 par contre oui je pense c'est un bon
coup j'ai peu de doutes dam des deux
voies là et commence à refaire de sa
carrière quatre mannequins ses gammes
bien c'est pas c'est pas serein quoi
ouais ouais ouais j'ai essayé j'ai su
cela à mes lequel kg 2 à cette aune en
effet 5
bon ben là je comprends que la comprends
plus rien ouais le la terre on a perdu
là tout le monde a buggé la même affaire
fouet cette pascal elle a vu qu'un léger
si ce n'avait été du foie jusqu'à cdmr
quatre matins
m oui c'est ça le 1
là il est allé le monde à la sedif wales
un faux f1 va faire je sais plus qui
attaque qui fait qui qui fait quoi
je comprends rien c'est sont paniqués
l'aller mais les deux là sont en panique
il y en a besoin
ok des blanchons gagne on and on éprouve
quelques jours la tour à tour n'oublie
pas là ça va ça va ça elle va prendre h5
prise chronique thoracique et 25,5 sous
les tours sont entre isabelle va
regarder absolue à ces terribles profond
ouais c'est un wave 2 t3f 5 cm et le
promoteur de co2 ouais elle prend pire
moment en fait et notre temps français 3
c'est hallucinant non mais c'est elle va
elle va la perdre
c'est terrible oh là là elle a rappelé
aux imprimés par cette prime va l'aider
cinq des six et elle va menacer mat
comme les faits donnent le cuir est pas
pour rien ouais attention c'est un jour
un nom et trois défaites
un logo plus rien la maturité de la
série ouais mais attends c'est pas fini
c'est la panique là où elle perd elle
repère une pièce elle la prend pas à
hausser la panique mathieu je comprends
pas ce qui se passe dames 100 jahre
simple on sait de 3v 3 à la paf hero 5
ça c'est gagner assez s'arrête sportif 1
2 ça s'arrête très sportif on a vu des
petits étirements côté kosteniuk bon
après alexandra elle peut se sentir
quand même favori et ce que j'ai
l'impression que et ça c'est pas de chef
de parti qui peut le rassurer
ouais je pense été rassurés en fait que
tu aies kosteniuk mais après moi je me
poserais des questions sur mon niveau de
jeu
ça les cinq saisons la vie derrière ça
ce qu'elle avait joué hier est là mais
peut-être nos tarifs et ses 50 ans le 17
et qu'on met un non non c'était pas la
même règle talk a été embellie après le
jeu b6 et si oui il y avait 6 et 6
exacte cela blesse si ce temps mais moi
j'aime bien pourquoi paquet
réponse il faut passer du latin moi je
dis moi je suis vraiment pas mon mule
est donc non mais c'est là tu vois je
sais pas et mieux c'est intéressant la
case bessin que je suis hyper content de
l'a5 en fait moi j'aimerais bien jeu à 7
à 5 à 7 pour les huit peut-être non mais
à cinq a et b étaient bizarres je vais
peut-être faire v6 mais après fallait un
peu calculé j'ai l'impression qu'en fait
ou chez nina elle calcule pas forcément
aussi dans des moments un peu bizarre
parfois et les 14 6 4
ça c'était jure avoir foi fuite
8 mais du coup ils commencent à préférer
le blanc oui petite préférence et
toujours les mêmes attaques et va faire
j'ai quatre et tout ça pleure la maison
c'est d'une puce une par contre je pense
oui il ya en plus un flash 5
comme d'hab en fait comme un pion
attaqué au bout d'un moment si elle sait
pas quoi faire elle le pousse bien joué
ça mais qu'avaient les achète par
quelques katas comprend pas un simple
prise qui avait réagi ce qu'ils achètent
ou pas j'ai l'impression que kader cissé
chaque équipe
c'est donc comme je te faire comprend
qu'ils aient progressé de 5,5
il relève 5 défend tout mathieu les
thèmes des jeunes des 6es le fou surtout
ses shows de knight mais je regardais en
fait sur la cam ou génial me paraît au
bord de la crise de nerfs à chaque coup
quoi j'ai pas si elle va si elle va s'en
sortir le même langage que je peux je
t'aimais je t'aime un peu de calme je
m'emploie que là c'est l'impression que
je pourrais pas faire de flèches mais je
te mets là calmes pour que tu puisse
voir tu as l'impression qu'elle au bord
de la crise de nerfs mais à chaque
moment quoi voilà encore il suffit que
je te la mets regardes tu sens des
rictus à chaque coup quoi mais c'est
bien joe quesada
oui atteint elle arrive à dominer la
finale pourtant l'essence est un peu
moins bien pour ces deux un tour ce 2
mai à la veille de bombes
instinct pendant là pendant la
compétition sans être exceptionnel mais
avait de bons instincts le regard elle
paraît tellement au bord de la calèche
est roi fayçal trois gammes ok rien de
spécial costumes qui font comment ça
qu'elle accélère un peu la gueule par
une spéciale en spéciale en fait à force
de rien faire de spécial sur pareil
quand tu es devant tu te tue contrôler
le match par montussan voilà je vais te
montre un peu la can j'ai retourné faire
des flèches mais tu sens qu'elle au bord
de la crise de nerfs non tu sens que ses
katas tu peux me et du coup elle à
réviser le fichier je pense est-ce
qu'elle va rejouer un 4/4 et les c4 à
dallas et je crois que c'est ça la ligne
parce que tu me l'as cannes est si tu
forces échange des fous et elle a gagné
une finale comme ça comme ça bon écoute
ça paraît plutôt pas d'être bien joué
battre mais bon un jour et je rajoute b3
et torcéen essayé de forcer à présent le
2 à la le pion isolé quand même en
finale c'est pas forcément le top ça
c'est plutôt pas mal pour pâques le
froid viennent mais tour des huit avec
le cab et rois et les rois avec deux
pour contrôler avec la zone 3 et le roi
est plus proche du centre même bien fait
recette qui quoi qu'ils essaient si ce
[Musique]
qu'est le quatre jeux commencent à
préférer les blancs c'est fou j'ai trois
intéressant dans polska l'aircap l'erika
radio 4 la gemme 14 et 5 g mais aussi
plus total à 44 maintenant là c'est le
bon tempo à 4 à 4 sans réfléchir
tu peux réfléchir à huy sont arrêtés à
pas la colonne des c'est pas bête
ouais elle la domine à la le pion à 5 en
ligne de mire à la carène et des six il
domine vraiment un
kosteniuk aux abois en stratégiquement
mathieu met au point un chacun a pris
détourage 5
c'est pas encore gagné mais ses pions
plus quand même dans ces quatre noms je
ressens est à dessein les 5 mais tu peux
prendre aussi peut-être non whatcott à
avoir est ce que si on prend un tour
prends toi prend elle la prendra 3 way
to say say say say say say say une
menace tout rochette et pour un set tu
fais tellement mal moi j'ai 5 roger 6
j'aurais fait roi g4 aussi marois g5 que
leurs amis les cinq sets à 1 à tours ce
nom sait et c'est très con de la même
manière
est ce que voulait faire un coup de
torts à celle d'avant 3,5 kg k325
clairement 3 ça c'est horrible comme co
5 et maintenant tu carton rouen 2 5i
justice rôle de 5 ces gagnants j'ai six
échecs et on prend à deux tours a subi
un échec échec chic bien sûr par la case
ou 6 3 juillet
oui bien sûr bien sûr très très bien je
vois là kosteniuk l / 100 g 5 croit
aussi steven asmat tu m'aimes pas un
parent a même pas parce qu'un bon bon
bon le away coûte géant verte et weening
bière ouais j'ai peut-être gagné ma
bière du 23 août l'a alors quelqu'un dit
il dit reste encore dix neuf minutes de
jeu
oui enfin pourquoi je suis désolé je
vais devoir partir très vite après parce
que j'ai démonté qui jouer à 21 il faut
qu'ils se connectent à 40 c'est parfait
c'est synchro c'est à dire que les deux
mondes banque lot doit s'occuper petit
en faire un jeu
de 16 heures en ce moment je n'ai pas
regardé nos deux démentent et bien sûr
visé mais juste j'ai peur de partout
chez les ch'tis par le pire halpern et
blanc au pirée le père mathieu comme ci
comme ça va vous prendre schiste n'y a
pas eu 6 mai 2003 pour les soins est
blanche
j'ai l'impression qu'alexandre elle en
train de craquer là et physiquement
c'est hyper dur de jeu si longtemps oui
non mais il ya le fait aussi que elle et
elle est quand même derrière toulon
stratégiquement et peut-être un moment
donné ça devient usant de devoir
remonter sur des tactiques
je pensais qu'ils allaient se faire
enfermer la dame franchement au signal
est remonté dans mon estime
non c'est une bonne chose bonne joueuse
mais qui est en fait je pense limiter en
partie longue
tactiquement je pense ouais mais sinon à
la l1 baugur là encore regard à la casse
des acquis et des salles avec les noirs
ça c'est plutôt bien joué qu'un pour un
nul qui est des cinq accosté nu comme
date qui repart pour essayer de faire
être tactique un ca non mais ouais mais
je n'ai pas vu mais le jour il ya un
match kosteniuk gunino ça doit être
génial récents voir ça envoie 46
secondes et en plus le gnl est mieux au
temps et roy a eu six résidents en faux
et faux hausse à 3,6 alors tu te places
19h05 aussi 5 geffroy tour c'est devrait
registre tournoi je ne comprends pas
venu alors ça c'est des cons
d'entraînement kombouaré dessus tu
donnes deux coups quoi après des fois
vas tu craques anglet les mêmes yeux le
faire et f5 et là ton idée à quatre
jours à trois tendances quoi oui oui
j'ai vu après le fait qu'il y ait des
ailes à deux points de retard l'oublient
pas oui mais bon est ce un café 4 aussi
de bien jouer cette coupe à mes parents
des jeux plus vite que débute dans trois
essais de la faudra un accueil ces trois
jours à qui ira parfaire à revenir en v5
bon sens à ces trois étaient protégés
mais c'est vrai la hat choc aux joues tu
mourrais la latte choc
alejo marrant ces trois voies
lalalalalala l'allier plus loin je
t'annonce qu'elle la paire avec les
noirs bref cinq secondes une pièce mais
vous n 5 elle veut pas jouer on sait pas
pourquoi dans la c est la cedh enlacés
dans la tête
mathieu peut-être un nul ouais là on sur
le stress kem lalot se seraient elles
ont lâché les coûts dans les premiers
bull est hélas très clairement il ya un
an c'est pas la première à combien cela
c'est vrai c'est celle qui en tête avant
la fin du chrono à la fin du chrono les
noirs c'est au final pas cela soldat
louis oui c'était eux on est en fait on
est toujours vous avez toujours la
caméra du don du bon côté quoi pour
savoir qui joue c'est la première à
19h38 voilà comme dix agents 78 78
donc il reste 15 minutes deux militants
que d'abonnés en plus 15 minutes 15
minutes on a quoi son camp il y avait
dix minutes ça fait trois parties voyage
fait cinq parties encore mathieu en gros
pour le suspense ce serait bien une
petite victoire de côté new look mais
qui s'est fait dominer à chaque fois son
système
oui à l'oeil du manager est alors grand
roque 5 et xénon web tv ce n'est pas
forcément la bonne le bon endroit pour
les questions perso comme ça là on est
en plein pendant la finale
alors est ce qu'il ya une vraie qui
empêche de faire comme icare 8 se lever
quand tu es devant metz et interdirait
sauf trouve un carreau oui je peux pas
te lever way normalement peut pas partir
donc carey lieu de 25 et j'ai fait ça
mais je pense que c'était pas sur les
speechs à je pense était sur le truc de
magnus est ce qu'elle va faire répéter
tu penses chantage à la nu la presse
kosteniuk elle n'est pas obligée de
panique un peu de refuser les nuls parce
que après elle reprend les blanquillos
sainte
il regarde les noirs ils ont raison oui
oui on commence à avoir un peu de gueule
dames 1 créat sap erp adams et vous ça
commence à prendre forme c'est vrai
mathieu salue la gueule tout est à peu
près tout est cohérent pas toutes les
pièces bon sens fait une tour en h7
peut-être avec les blancs pour essayer
de un jour suivant a planté un caïd est
ici soit un truc comme ça
après il se passe quoi baisser fini
c'est ce que quelques de points gagnés
c'est la fin du tournoi ça faisait un
moins de compétition on va fêter ça
d'ailleurs ça fait un mois sans compter
la la phase de qualification à la compet
ça démonte et a joué un peu sinon ça
fait un mois et demi de complète en tout
en comptant la phase de calibrage
commence à dominer autour des 2 nous mes
vieux troyes et encore les pionners mais
c'est bien joué ça enfin cela maintenant
ça va pour les blancs non ckt fun
t'as pas trop si je pensais qu'elle à
réussir à rentrer en première rangée
mais un autre hacker d2 bien joué c'est
chaud c'est très chaud mathieu tête tour
eiffe 55 kg 4 des bouquets des quatre
moments c'est terrifiant un joueur qui
est franchi et français quatre quais ou
trois mais qu'elles pensent les 4e et 5e
à baisser alors à 4 du coup c'est des
grosses et les gros sabots
du coup les blancs song émana réception
de plus mais tout peut arriver puisque
air du temps allez on fait quoi c'est
mieux qu'elle a déposée de sarnaut et
signe un jeu tout impôt j'avais pas fait
gaffe autant c'est la folie comme valeo
monte
oui whaou qui a aidé 4 qui arrive cinq
gars jouer ses trois ratés ou des deux
tu perds leurs pions on s'était dit que
c'était fin du game foods 2 1 qui avait
fait pas mal qui a aidé 5 sûrement qui
est français trois tours c4 elle doit
faire ça le sénat va la perdre
j'apprends bk très bien joué et ses deux
neveux
ouais ça va 100 ça ça fait peur mais
savoureux 4 vendu un des trois c'est
temps d'accès chez pentax bond
allez une bonne connexion non on a peur
mais elle est demandée connexion
correcte qu'elle prendrait si ça c'est
l'angola est là c'est là ces longues
hésitations mais là c'est la m voilà là
mais un coup d'accélérateur mais elle a
une bonne pointe de vitesse en pâte km
oui oui elle joue vite balle et quand
même 25 60 en bullet c'est un peu moins
fort que moi mais pas de beaucoup
non pas que je sois un génie du bullet
mais tout à gagner du temps c'est pas
con
ouais écoute il reste plus que 11
minutes saclay toutes les nuls commence
à être des petites victoires maintenant
pour pour ou chez nina way et il ya un
mag est donc possible ou pas en cas de
nul je crois qu'elle rejoue des partis
dans tout les cadences ou alors ils ont
changé la règle et il vous 2-2 bullet
mais au pire si tu dois partir tu
pareils à patrice ya pas de y'a pas y'a
pas eu besoin rock qui est pensé de bout
seulement 1,5 fois que oui mais tu es
content avec les noirs tu vas faire des
5 et l'om et tanguay ainsi s'il est pas
terrible et blanc ont joué cavalier 2 kg
3 ces tranches je suis d'accord mais ton
flandre à trois c'est maintenant salle
du sens je serais pas allé en reste six
parce que j'aurais bien voulu mettre mon
fou donc attractive droit et donc du
coup un jour on trouve que j'ai dit que
je sais qu'à ses saints que c'est
toujours bon en fait c'est très rare ce
sol où ça arrive mais c'est rare
normalement la norme c'est que c'est
plutôt mauvais nom est bond il ya une
ligne de la française d'arbres la
présidence tchèque correct 2 au tessin
est ce que b 5 6 et un coup c'est trop
dangereux d'affaiblir ses 6 certains
n'ont même pas vraiment bien parce que
des cinq blessés la faiblesse à les ans
ici ce sera assez facile à absorber 5 à
damas un temple du site fait pour 8 tu
réfléchis pas trop
suite à ma vie à 8 c'est bien moins
quatre peut-être je pense tu fais d'un
mac a d'ailleurs 3 2 3 à 3 3
c'est pas bête que l'autre s'y attend
pas c'est attendu t attends pas cracher
sur les je suis d'accord cette cadence
elle bloque la merlin le pendule par
seconde à 20 secondes avance pour pour
alexandra en fait le moment je pense que
avec sandra et doit doit essayer de bien
jouer à mon nom oui et l apal équilibre
encore mais attend elle peut le trouver
un elle doit tenter des pièges à un
moment donné je n'ai fait que ça ouais
c'est bien joué ça je suis donc là il ya
même un f5 sinon j'aurais pris aussi un
tamm 1 6l te dis juste je vais faire nul
ou chez nina vraiment à ce moment du
match
elle est devant il reste avec ses 8
c'est un coup de phryne c'est l'anti
après move et d'amal 5 annonce ainsi
twin twin non plus cette série parce que
c'est une saveur du temps tu sais même
si tu la gagnes tu devrais après appris
resquilleurs et suit minute si tu
reviens au score tu es quand même pas
mal hein enfin il reste une minute si le
mec s'est pas trompé dans le choix d'un
nom est de là que s'est pas trompé en d4
était une menace avec damien 4 à la
raison alexandra elle elle doit elle
doit changer de parti une nouvelle ruche
j'ai subi exactement d'accord d'ailleurs
ou chine a rendu la joie oui
jamais jamais nakamura fait de me suis
démené cet appel est peut-être plus
stable aussi n'a qu'a donc il reste quoi
ici reste 7 minutes de jeu il en reste
il reste deux ou trois classes ni
groenefeld
ah ouais non mais là ça devient ça
devient la crise côté kosteniuk ça c'est
une grande ligne de vos crimes
les deux ailes et deux journalistes
djaafar c'est extraordinaire je pense à
grunwald or prépa c'est mieux pour les
noirs en bullet n'arrête pour les blancs
sont elles censées connaît tuning mais
je pas forcément faux f4 bon écoute puis
car elle a par exemple je réponds oui
kyle vsab et 5 voilà feu 3 c'est n14 de
broc fonds speech à ce qu'ils aient
accès étaient barrés non mais parade
nous on ne fait partie des gens on voit
pas l'intérêt de continuer quand c'est
déjà fini
ou comme oui madame annick c'est une
façon à lui de dire que votre système
est con ça me choque pas tant que ça non
c'est pas c'était pas sur un match serré
il parle et donne donc 35 secondes
contre 30 c'est à peu près équilibré où
je gagne 17 à quel point ces trois là
c'est bizarre que du coup je viens de me
faire penser ça que les noirs commencent
est mieux ouais tour de la faire tourner
ses 8 tu penses v8 tour des huit mabiala
est là l employé tes conseils elle a un
peu ralenti kosteniuk elle arrive
saunier quelque chose pas le truc c'est
que elle est en fait juste à la main et
des papilles fortus clermont pas donc il
faut à la besoin de s'employer parce que
c'est une très forte de nos colonnes
mais france et rhône oui je gagne le
pion aux pieds ça va être chaud chaud
bouillant elle va revenir à mon sens
normalement elle devrait revenir à -1 5
minutes normalement il doit revenir à -1
il restera deux partir et c'est chaud
mais s'avère qu'elle peut elle peut
prendre là nul dans la prochaine après
la loi un volet chrono comment ça marche
théoriquement ils peuvent les voir mais
aussi de cette eau
à l'enfilade c'est dommage bon après
tellement plus de temps à côté
d'ukrainiens vacances et une baisse
symétrique et la gnac lancé en plus ils
donnent trois os il va tomber juste tu
peux pas un bon bouquin fait un point
d'écart de deux parties à jouer mathieu
c'est simple il faut ou chez nina si
elle gagne une partie s'est gagné
kosteniuk qui a besoin d'un point et
demi pour égaliser deux points pour
gagner au moins c'est simple donc elle
rejoue un rouge ou celle là l'accueil 17
petit rock et ses 5 allait pousser être
quatre à la pression avec geste is ok
est-ce qu'elle va reprendre du poumon
détroit s'est imposé alors faire j'ai si
c'est la même
c'était une faute trois fois 5 il ya une
partie n avais pas je fous trois mains
ça nous paraissait plus logique aussi à
toi la navy la réviser oui que c'est une
va remonter auris hybrid est un bien ses
quatre tours d un c4 à leurs gagnants
à mon avis elle va faire plus que
remonté à elle va égaliser à la c4 mais
je pensais peut-être est obligé de faire
faut aussi une foule si ce qui c 3 c'est
fini juste et duquel une prépa 1 quand
tu qu'elle ne comptait pas dans un match
comme ça c'est rien la grosse nouvelle
et puis en plus tu l'as cannes en bullet
sait il faut s'en rappeler ambühl est ce
pas si simple mais la relève est là
révisé entre les trucs oui à mon avis
est il ya quelqu'un qu'il est d'un train
j'espère c'est de bonne guerre c'est
autorisé c'est normal même ce serait
content pour vous tenir à l'abri c'est
pas simple à gagner c'est un peu faire
traîner la partie puisque font un cadre
si j'arrive à mettre le stabiliser
damphousse et cinq ici peu une idée pour
le séjour des footballeurs qui jouent
avec ses 5 dams dame b 7 1 pour jouer
toutes les cases blanches
cette danse et s'amuse et 3 mai
h4 j'aime j'ai quatre mois j 7 en duel
elle donne qu'à réaliser trois peut-être
c3 il faut ici ce qui est kabyle est un
peu pâle entre 2,5 et ralph 500 faisait
6l cinq dessins plutôt bien joli bébé 3
pts alors je garde tout assez tendue
matthieu dallon alain barrès cinq tours
de 3 des trois salles archi en gros 5 5
mais c'est hyper bizarre d'aller c'est
bien joué bien les aidera ces orages
pourront chine ne pas avoir calé elle a
atteint touré maire francis cinq mois et
tout s'effondre puisqu'il a g6 qui
traîne ses égalisation à deux minutes de
la fin sénat temps c'est pas tout à fait
finie en plus on voit quand même plein
de coups de butoir c'est terrible quand
à chaque fois seul coup tu te prends
aussi f5
ouais mais attends attends tu entends la
fine la finale faut encore la gagne et
mathieu distingue encore faire des think
tomber cannes story 5 ça commence dans
laquelle trois week-ends c'est bien mais
comme nous les coûts papa de fautes donc
faire égaliser reste deux minutes
mathieu et les deux jouaient ce qu'ils
vont être à égalité à deux minutes de la
fin d'un senior kahn ont été vendus
c'est vrai mais bon nul c'est quand même
assez improbable
quoique assez terrible c'est terrible
mathieu toute façon c'était fini donc ça
fait avoir les deux joueuses qui sont
vraiment même niveau quand on avait
annoncé un match sérieux s'étaient pas
trompés en tout cas un ennemi très et
demi 3 1 lui job là vraiment ça va se
jouer ça va jouer ici à ça va se jouer
sur ça c'est là il on trouve que les
blancs mais maîtrisent mais la dernière
fois les noirs ont peu de problèmes ou
la cave au lieu qu'elles cathala changé
à la paf est aussi c'est quoi l'idée je
prends un caïd et 2 ouais tu vas faire 4
mais là ça va jouer sur les nerfs
mathieu tu peux me mettre là car mon
tout petit a longtemps je peux regarder
en cas mais pas faire de fléchin on peut
regarder en cas de nous aussi comme un
câble
comme les gens aient jugé le un peu
bouger la souris s'il le faut il faut
trois des six valeureux mais le pion des
6 un peu comme tout à leur nom a manqué
là tu veux faire plus des 6 aussi ce
qu'est cette enclave dauphin on sera six
à cinq mois je pense est un mauvais coup
à 5 j'aime pas mais bon c'est 6 pouces
et 4 vient d'être le jeu avec eux sains
ou la lgv est une genre de méthode ruiz
f4 c'est super bien joué elle mathieu le
stress le stress est à son comble en
présence de sa vie ouais ou chez nina
elle est vraiment vous de ça vire c'est
terrible un jeu sans créneau ont gagné
s'était changée gagner va bien à ses
passions je commence à aimer les noirs
c'est terrible c'est pas sûr ça marche
elle va faire des cinq dessins je
voulais cazelles jouer à la mûre parce
qu'ils avaient lieu 4 à savatan du
mathieu tours 1-3 autour de 8,2 me
points reçoit mais du coup ça peut faire
du luxe est terrible aïe ça peut ça peut
mettre un tube et 3 ça à mon avis a fait
nul mathieu mathieu qui doit renouveler
ou quitter non mais c'est pas grave je
commençais tranquille là et là c'est
impossible quand une partie non c'est
même pas une partie ça mériterait de
faire annuler dalle en départage ce
histoire mais à côté nous qui est trop
mieux au temps là ouais après midi dont
j'ai cinq tours à chaque validé c'est
juste de jouer des coups comme elle fait
maintenant et puis de te mettre ma
l'otan moi j'ai trois ans j'ai trois
barrières fou 3 c'est très con tour ces
deux maintenant l épreuve du coup tu es
prêt nous faut trois tours ces deux
tours l2 normalement oui un banal pour
monter à la gamme 17 secondes
oui oui et puis surtout kosteniuk en
fait elle commence à être mal autant
aussi donc à un moment donné c'est pas
dit que ça tourne bien pour toi avec les
noirs
voilà maintenant c'est ta aucun avantage
et
et les blancs et les blancs savent ce
qu'ils font mais peut-être b4e merde à
table elle a oublié de faire flouer
trois prêtres et 3,5 d'essayer 6 elle va
faire d'amd 9 holla holla la tête de
kosteniuk quand elle a vu coup mathieu
c'est génial oh la la dame b cette
hausse est terrible cette fin deux
parlent de 6 ouais mais le roi le roi
repart de l'autre côté il ya rien ce
poste vous voilà ella ella rae mesdames
bessette et de fou prend et froid oh la
la tour f 1 c'est terrible mathieu le
pion à qui parle j'en peux plus matthew
des 5 es fou froid or c'est bien je sais
aussi web et puis on prend j'ai trois
pions prend ya peut-être rien olala j'en
peux plus mathieu assez irrespirable à
l'option acquis par ancien second use on
sait bien jouer non mais peut-être pas
ce qu'il ya le fou qui revient en g2
mathieu c'est incroyable oh ça
incroyable ce parti défait des échecs et
n'est qu'un os à être perpète
vois tu dois faire perpète hausse non au
elle va faire ton proche des eaux
prochain c'est incroyable mathieu solde
est la décision d'alger 2 elle va
abandonner au c'est fini mathieu assez
incroyable oh c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable je crois que c'est la
dernière à c'était la dernière hausse et
incroyants regarde la tête de kosteniuk
écoeuré
au final et surprise ça ma part entre
grosses dena parti pour preuve cinq des
six dames des 5 c'est beau ouais c'était
fou non franchement belle fin de
compétition c'est cool ah ouais nan là
c'est un joli match mathieu un hacker
souris c'est assez rare de la voir
sourire comme le voilà les deux sont
allés au bout du suspense moi je prends
une longue
bon allez je dois vous laisser je suis
désolé bah écoute moi aussi donc on
ferme le stream merci à tous d'avoir
suivi la servicisation et on se retrouve
bientôt ciao ciao
merci encore